l'après-midi monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer monsieur
Darmanin merci de
votre présence afin qu'il nous présente
finalement deux sujets importants dans
un premier temps le projet loi
d'orientation est programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur connu sous
l'acronyme l'OPI nos deux rapporteurs
sont sont là puis nous évoquerons en
deuxième partie l'État les moyens de la
sécurité civile en raison des événements
difficiles et graves que nous avons vécu
cet été
quelques mots sur la genèse de la loopy
et les longues évidemment le projet de
loi fait suite à l'élaboration du Livre
blanc de la sécurité intérieure je
regarde Henri Leroy rendu en public
qu'en 2020 puis alors les nations du
Beauvau la sécurité je regarde à nouveau
en roi conclut l'année dernière pourquoi
je regarde parce que c'est lui qui nous
représentait dans ses débats le
gouvernement a d'abord déposé un premier
projet de 32 articles 16 mars dernier
avant de redéposer un nouveau projet de
loi plus resserré qui est maintenant sur
bureau notre assemblée le 7 septembre
dernier le texte viendra en séance
publique je le rappelle le 10 et en
commission une semaine avant
je voudrais insister sur le fait que
deux articles programmatiques présentent
les orientations du ministère intérieur
pour les 5 prochaines années et
prévoyant d'ailleurs une augmentation de
son budget en cumulé de 15 milliards
d'euros et très articles en caractère
normatif
c'est interrogation sur d'autant plus
légitime au moment où nous parlons que
l'ensemble des scientifiques de façon
quasi unanime prévoit un accroissement
de ce type de risque et donc de la
fréquence de ces incendies monsieur le
ministre je vais vous céder la parole
dans quelques secondes naturellement
ensuite nous rapporteurs sans doute
peut-être la possibilité de
souhaiteront-ils vous poser quelques
questions bien sûr mais Françoise Dumont
qui sur l'aspect sécurité civile et
notre rapporteur au sein de la
commission aura aussi quelques questions
et puis les collègues bien évidemment
qui le souhaiteront voilà j'ai été
beaucoup trop long je rappelle que cette
audition est
retransmise sur le site internet du
Sénat également chez le ministre vous
avez la parole
merci merci monsieur le Président Madame
la rapporteur messieurs les rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
merci de votre invitation je voudrais
d'abord excuser Jean-François caraco qui
était prévu de venir avec moi mais il a
pu être envoyé par moi-même et par le
Président de la République et
l'après-midi sera en Guadeloupe je suis
aux événements terribles que connaissent
cobatriotes de Guadeloupe mais j'en suis
sûr nous parlerons Nouvelle-Calédonie
dans un temps qui sera votre disposition
et très bientôt si vous le souhaitez
bien évidemment revenir en effet
monsieur le Président sur la loi
d'orientation de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur c'est une loi
très importante pour le ministère qui
tombe à prénommé en début de mandat
comme son a dit qu'une loi de
programmation ce qui n'est jamais arrivé
au ministère de l'Intérieur puisqu'il y
a eu des lobsi des lois d'orientation de
programmation de sécurité intérieure
mais jamais de l'opmie qui concernait
l'intégralité du ministère d'intérieur
et que l'ensemble des crédits concerne
le titre que j'ai l'honneur de portée
budgétairement et jamais en
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur en tant que tel et si je
pouvais
pour parler ça serait super et qui par
ailleurs ministre s'exprimer par
ailleurs nous permettrait puisque ce
ministère aujourd'hui évoque une
configuration géographique qui n'avait
jamais connu dans ses compétences à la
fois les outre-mer les réformes
institutionnelles du ministère de
l'intérieur on pense au Grand Paris à la
Corse bien évidemment à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie à la réforme
territoriale voulue par le président de
la République à la lutte contre le cyber
qui n'existait pas dans les années 80 à
90 bien évidemment et de manière
générale à toutes les difficultés que
peut connaître notre pays puisque au
ministère de l'Intérieur la difficulté
est sans doute que pris par les crises
de successives et par l'actualité nous
concentrons sur des choses à quelques
jours et quelques semaines ou quelques
mois mais nous n'avons besoin sans doute
de moyens budgétaires étendus 15
milliards d'euros qui sur cinq ans vont
permettre une transformation profonde du
ministère de l'intérieur dont la moitié
de ces 15 milliards iront au cyber et au
numérique ce qui veut dire à deuxième
point la marche
technologique que fait le Minister sera
je l'espère et toute proportion gardée
semblable à ce que le ministère des
armées a connu à la fin de la
conscription et au début de l'armée de
métier de sa technologie à Sion je
voudrais attirer l'attention que cette
Lemmi évidemment est divisée en deux
types d'articles je pourrais distinguer
le premier et les autres le premier avec
un rapport indexé très long qui prévoit
le l'orientation et la programmation
budgétaire de ce que nous souhaitons
faire et qui résume finalement
l'ambition de la loi d'orientation de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur il y avait dans le premier
texte déposant conseil ministre des
dispositions plus nombreuses sur l'image
notamment les statues de l'image
souhaitée par la CNIL et par le Conseil
d'État soit l'adaptation de la
vidéoprotection aux critères rgpd
désormais sur l'intelligence
artificielle de statut d'image de
manière générale qui nous a occupé voilà
la dernière année et il a été jugé plus
sage le retirer
disposition et de pouvoir soit proposer
au Parlement parce qu'on a vu qu'au
Sénat monsieur le Président en rapport
avait été rendu par vos excellents
rapporteurs qu'elle assemblée également
entre un député LR et un député MoDem à
rapport ce rendu sous trois mois et donc
soit dans une loi Jeux Olympiques soit
dans une proposition de loi que
porterait le Parlement le statut de
l'image qui est un moment important pour
les commissions des lois
particulièrement serait étudiés éclairé
des travaux parlementaires notamment
parce qu'on en a besoin pour
l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques je
reviens sur mon article premier et cet
article premier il permet de faire pour
être dire trois grandes constatations de
transformation du ministère de
l'Intérieur d'abord le doublement c'est
l'objectif fixé par le président de la
République dans son discours de Roubaix
et puis de Nice le doublement de la
présence de voies publiques des
policiers et des et des gendarmes ce
doublement de la présence de voie
publique tire comme conclusion que la
police la gendarmerie depuis au moins
les attentats terroristes 2015
dans une police qui fonctionne beaucoup
en intervention intervention terroriste
nous l'avons dit en intervention tout
court et qui mériterait sans doute de se
voir améliorer dans sa présence de voie
publique puisqu'on voit que si la lutte
contre le terrorisme si j'ose dire
fonctionne je rappelle que sur les 10
milliards d'euros du quinquennat
précédent sur la sécurité intérieure et
sur les 10000 créations de poste 40 % de
ses créations de poste ont été à la DGSI
au renseignement territoriaux la DGCI a
vu son budget doublé 39 attentats ont
été déjoués depuis 5 ans et demi
désormais et nous sommes sortis de
l'état d'urgence terroriste pour entrer
et grâce notamment à l'application du
Sénat à des dispositions dures et des
moyens supplémentaires pour lutter
contre cette menace terroriste et si on
peut considérer que cette stratégie
antiterroriste fonctionne nous voyons
que notamment ce indicateurs de violence
faite aux personnes continuellement et
surtout depuis le covid celle-ci
augmente sans doute par manque de
présence de voie publique des Pol des
gendarmes pour dire ce raisons qu'il
nous faut résoudre par cette loi
d'orientation de programmation d'abord
la recréation d'effectifs de sécurité
publique on a commencé à le faire sur le
quinquennat précédent il faut évidemment
le continuer et constater aussi que
l'augmentation des violences se fait
davantage en zone gendarmerie qu'en zone
de police ce qui ne paraît pas intuitif
même si l'urbanisation a fait que des
grandes villes désormais sont dans la
zone gendarmerie un certain nombre de
lieux de territoires notamment je pense
au monde agricole qui subit aujourd'hui
beaucoup de difficultés et beaucoup de
constatations de violence ou de
cambriolages méritent de faire un effort
particulier pour la gendarmerie
nationale d'où par exemple la création
des 200 brigades de gendarmerie
supplémentaires dans les 5 ans qui
viennent je rappelle que depuis 20 ans
nous avons supprimé 500 brigades de
gendarmerie et sa première fois que la
République depuis 20 ans va retour donc
je rappelle que d'ailleurs l'essentiel
sont des dénonciations d'atteintes aux
mineurs mais il y a aussi évidemment des
attentes
aux valeurs de la République qui a
commencé par des appels au meurtres
terroristes on voit bien que nous devons
désormais décliner l'intégralité des
politiques publiques de sécurité y
compris dans le monde dans le monde
numérique il s'agit pas de créer une
direction du cyber à côté d'autres
directions la Direction de la Sécurité
publique la direction de la police aux
frontières mais que chaque direction est
à la fois abra cyber et un bras dans le
monde réel puisque les deux évidemment
communiquent si j'ose dire entre dans le
monde des délinquants il faut donc de le
faire dans le monde dans le monde réel
ce qui veut dire donc sur les 15
milliards d'euros un peu plus de 7
milliards d'euros sont consacrés à cette
transformation numérique avec la
création d'une agence unique du
numérique au ministère de l'Intérieur
aujourd'hui chaque force a ses principes
de sécurité cyber un renforcement très
fort des offices et notamment des poly
judiciaires des deux armes y compris
aussi de la DGSI et de la PP pour
pouvoir enquêter sur le sur le
cyberespace des moyens juridiques comme
vous verrez dans la loopnie notamment la
saisie d'actifs numériques bientôt
aujourd'hui pas possible dans le monde
de la délinquance on peut saisir des
actifs physiques mais pas des actifs
numériques alors que une partie des
rançons par exemple sont payés
évidemment en monnaie numérique et bien
sûr une formation qui doit entraîner la
formation du policier du gendarme de ses
chefs bien évidemment mais aussi de des
gardiens de la paix et des gendarmes de
brigade puisque désormais des épreuves
de codage des examens sur titre des
formations dans le cyberespace seront
fait pour chacun des passages en école
de police et gendarmerie puisque 1500
cyber patrouilleurs seront créés dans le
quinquennat pour pouvoir effectivement
mener à bien ses enquêtes qui touchent
bien sûr pas simplement les grandes
entreprises du CAC 40 mais on l'a vu
encore très récemment soit les consignes
nos concitoyens qui ne savent pas
comment faire devant de telles menaces
soit des petites collectivités des
hôpitaux publics ou des PME avec cette
transformation numérique je voudrais
insister sur un point particulièrement
où vous nous demandons pour l'instant
une habilitation mais j'ai promis le
rapporteur qu'elle serait transformée en
dur dans le texte au Sénat sur le réseau
radio du futur c'est un point
extrêmement important ça coûte 2
milliards d'euros finances publiques et
c'est un projet porté par le Vista
d'intérieur au nom de la terre
ministérialité en quoi cela consiste
nous avons constaté dans la vallée de la
Vésubie et de la Roya dernièrement
c'était le gars encore encore cet été et
de manière générale dans les grands
événements que nous connaissons que les
réseaux de chacun chacune des forces les
pompiers les gendarmes les policiers les
plus on pourrait penser à
l'administration pénitentiaire on
pourrait penser évidemment à un certain
nombre d'autres actions notamment du
ministère de la Santé ces réseaux radio
sont anciens et ne fonctionnent pas
toujours lorsqu'il y a des crises ce qui
évidemment est extrêmement embêtant pour
gérer la vie de crise et le réseau radio
du futur consiste à faire un seul unique
réseau de radio pour l'État qui permet
non seulement de passer des ondes mais
des images puisque la radio de demain
n'est pas qu'une radio d'onde on ne
décrit plus une personne on envoie des
images en utilisant les images des
vidéoprojection des câbles à piétons on
peut imaginer une municipalité des
drones multiplicité d'image et notamment
qu'on soit prêt pour les Jeux Olympiques
avec ce réseau radio nouveau tu auras
comme énorme avantage également non
seulement de faire un réseau unique pour
la première fois dans l'histoire du
monde ce sont des industriels français
qui ont d'ailleurs gagné l'appel
d'offres et qui nous espérons
permettront d'exporter ce savoir-faire à
l'étranger une fois réussi à l'occasion
des Jeux Olympiques et qui permet
évidemment à chacune et à chacun de
simplifier la vie d'une concitoyens si
je devais résumer dans le calcaire
précédent on a transformé les outils
compliqués et informatiques de ou le
papier parfois des policiers des
gendarmes avec leurs numéros néo
c'est-à-dire le téléphone portable
fabriqué en France d'ailleurs dans une
très belle PME d'Aix-en-Provence qui
s'appelle crosscall désormais les
policiers gendarmes ils ont chacun une
tablette Neo qui est en fait un
téléphone qui téléphone qui fait passage
au fichiers qui permet de mettre les
amendes et qui permet de faire toutes
les démarches à distance sans jamais
rentrer au commissariat de la brigade de
gendarmerie l'étape 2 vous permettre que
c'est néo soit aussi leur radio et donc
on va d'un côté la radio de l'autre leur
téléphone mais tout sur leur téléphone
ce qui permettra d'ailleurs pour les
filatures d'être plus discret plutôt que
vous allez voir cette radio qui déforme
parfois les jeans ou les chemises de nos
policiers ou de dos ou de nos gendarmes
ce réseau radio du futur est un des
symboles très important et prend 2
milliards des 7 milliards que nous vous
demandons pour la transformation
numérique de l'ensemble du ministère
intérieur de vous aurez compris qui
touche aussi la sécurité civile et la
gestion des crises le troisième sujet
c'est évidemment un sujet de meilleur
organisation du ministère de l'Intérieur
dans dans sa gestion des cris justement
soit en sécurité civile avec notamment
le renouvellement l'intégralité de nos
hélicoptères notamment je pense aux 35
hélicoptères de la sécurité civile les
moyens donnés au préfet lors de la
gestion de crise qui est une disposition
extrêmement importante puisque vous
voyez bien qu'il y a une sorte de
difficulté dans la commande des crises
de l'État lorsque ces crises quelle
qu'elle soit arrivent avec la
multiplicité des acteurs ou de manière
générale de la réorganisation des
déprésfectures même sur un volet
étranger qui viendra dans un projet de
loi futur monsieur le Président qui je
crois sera présenté aussi en premier au
Sénat permettra de faire une continuité
avec avec
cette des dispositions prévues dans cet
article premier qui sont très importants
et qui dessine finalement ce que doit
être au ministère de l'Intérieur de
demain permettez-moi de souligner
peut-être une autre disposition qui est
prévue en tout cas des dispositions qui
peuvent résumer aussi la loopnie c'est
un très gros travail autour de
l'investigation si je devais résumer
notre difficulté c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
sécurité publique est bien plus présente
qu'elle ne l'était encore il y a 4 5 ans
dans les rues il y a beaucoup plus
d'interpellations on a à peu près 100%
de saisie de drogue en plus sur 5 ans on
a à peu près 80% de trafiquants
interpellé de plus on a évidemment des
violences conjugales dont la parole est
recueillie davantage à 400 000 désormais
dossiers par an pour les policiers
légendaires bref on a multiplié les
motifs de garde à vue d'enquête avec une
efficacité
notamment sur un certain nombre de
politiques publiques mais il faut une
fois qu'on a arrêté des gens pouvoir
faire des enquêtes et donc il faut des
enquêteurs et donc il faut une police
d'investigation et donc nous faisons
sauter à cet homme de verrou sur
l'investigation aujourd'hui dans le
texte de loi je pense notamment à cette
disposition qui prévoyait qu'il faut
attendre 3 ans pour devenir OPJ en
sortant d'école et c'est un des
problèmes du ministre de l'Intérieur et
parfois vous m'écrivez pour avoir des
OPJ dans vos commissariats pour ce qui
concerne les zones de police le mise
intérieur ne peut pas affecter des
personnes en dehors de ce sortie d'école
dans les commissariats il ne peut
couvrir des postes et si les gens ne
vont pas spontanément sur ces postes
nous constater que ces postes ne sont
pas remplis et l'une des difficultés
c'est qu'en sortant seulement les
policiers des commissariats des écoles
de gardien de la paix dans les
commissariats je ne peux affecter aucun
EPJ puisque par nature une disposition
légale m'empêche de leur faire passer le
concours avant les trois ans de latence
pour pouvoir passer le bloc OPJ et donc
avec l'augmentation de la durée de
formation des grains de la paix qui
passent de 8 à 12 mois dont ceux qui
sont actuellement en école vivent la
première fois ce que nous avons proposé
au Parlement l'année dernière il
passeront tous le bloc OPJ ce qui leur
permettra peut-être pas tous de le
réussir mais tout le monde aura des
cours de droit sur numerer ce qui n'est
un mal pour personne et ceux qui
l'auront réussi auront donc leur
qualifications au BJ et pourront être
envoyés directement dans les
commissariats il y a évidemment d'autres
dispositions autour de l'investigation
mais je voulais particulièrement
souligner cette dispositions très
attendues des services de police depuis
extrêmement longtemps voilà monsieur le
Président sur la question de la loi
d'orientation on aura une discussion en
commission sur chacun des articles et
sur le long en rapport indexé et donc ce
sera une très bonne chose sans doute de
le détailler je voudrais peut-être
souligner le point particulier de la
sécurité civile que vous m'avez évoqué
et revenir avec vous sur ce que nous
avons connu cet été qui depuis si je
peux me permettre une correction
monsieur le Président 1976 n'a pas connu
de déforestation par le feu aussi
importante
alors on peut considérer mais évidemment
chacun peut avoir l'opinion qui le
souhaite que dans des conditions
d'extrême tension pour l'appareil de
sécurité civile nous n'avons à déplorer
aucun mort ni de la part des soldats du
feu direct au feu ni de la part des
personnes touristes ou citoyens qui se
trouvaient sur ces lieux de feu qui sont
multipliés sur le territoire national et
le nombre de destructions d'habitation a
été extrêmement limitée tout en ayant
aucune opération de de pillage réussie
de la part des délinquants puisque les
difficultés lorsqu'on fait vider un
certain nombre de villes et de villages
et il y a eu jusqu'à 100 000 personnes
qui ont quitté leur habitation pendant
cet été sous la pression si je veux dire
du feu on peut considérer que par
ailleurs la coopération était polices et
avec les gendarmerie ce sont déroulées
le mieux le mieux possible cependant
plusieurs
conséquences sont attirés sans doute de
cette situation qui est due au
réchauffement climatique n'ont pas
forcément l'origine mais par le biotope
qui l'entoure je m'explique 9 feux sur
10 sont d'origine humaine soit parce que
c'est volontaire les Pyroman soit parce
que c'est involontaire le comportement
non citoyen d'un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes mais le fait que le
réchauffement climatique soit fort
et notamment que le taux d'hydrométrie a
été de moins de 10% par exemple en
Gironde ce qui fait que c'était
une vraie cheminée si j'ose dire au
moment où le feu est arrivé couplé à des
vents extrêmement violents dans certains
endroits qui changeaient par ailleurs de
de de voix couplé au fait que une grande
partie des forêts n'étaient pas
entretenu je rappelle que sur 100% des
forêts qui ont brûlé cet été 90% étaient
privés et 10% seulement étaient
publiques et donc on va bien notamment
qu'en Gironde la question qui s'est
posée c'est comment les pompiers
pouvaient intervenir dans des forêts qui
n'étaient pas entretenues avec pas de
chemin de passage pour les véhicules de
pompiers par exemple fait que nous
devons à coup sûr changer notre modèle
de sécurité civile au fur et à mesure
que le réchauffement climatique vient
toucher nos territoires je voudrais
d'ailleurs attirer votre attention que
même s'il a eu il y a eu dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône ou dans le Vaucluse un
certain nombre de feux cet été
l'essentiel des feux n'a pas été dans le
dans les bars dans le Var encore ou dans
les Bouches-du-Rhône ce qui est
habituellement les lieux de feu les plus
intenses mais la Gironde qui n'avait pas
connu ces feux
et qui ont surpris je crois une très
grande partie de la population et du 10
de Gironde ça a été le cas aussi en
Maine-et-Loire c'était le cas dans le
Finistère et c'était le cas dans le Jura
bref il y a eu quasiment autant de feux
au nord de la Loire au sud de la Loire
alors qu'on sait tous que c'est en
général au sud de la Loire que la saison
des feux est la plus la plus intense je
vois d'ailleurs attirer votre attention
que saisons des feux ne veut plus dire
grand-chose désormais puisque il
commence très tôt là ils ont commencé
quasiment dès la fin mais alors que
d'habitude c'est début juillet et ils
vont continuer très tard puisque
jusqu'en décembre on peut penser qu'il y
aura des feux dans le sud de la France
et encore si tu fais notamment du
réchauffement climatique
mais il est évident que c'est surtout
par la terre qu'on le gagne et il y a
manifestement à se poser des questions
qu'on se posait déjà voilà quelques mois
sur les matériels et le soutien
financier et moral que l'on peut
apporter à nos sapeurs-pompiers qui
soient professionnels volontaire selon
certains départements et il y a des
départements aujourd'hui qui n'étaient
même pas équipés contre des feux de
forêt ou très peu je pense au Jura je
pense aux Vosges je pense aux
Maine-et-Loire je pense au Finistère
parce que pas habitué assez difficultés
de feu et c'est bien normal que
désormais on doit pouvoir accompagner
ces investissements investissements
supplémentaires il y a sans doute
monsieur le Président a travaillé sur le
financement des 10 qui est un sujet
extrêmement important la priorisme m'a
demandé de demander à l'igéa un rapport
que je communiquerai au Parlement sur le
financement des 10 et notamment la bonne
utilisation de la taxe sur les
assurances qui est aujourd'hui versées
au département et qui ensuite est
reversé de manière incomplète au 10
parce que les départements eux-mêmes ont
des dépenses sociales sans doute qui ne
sont pas compensées par ailleurs mais à
la fin c'est la sécurité civile si j'ose
qui subit ces difficultés financières et
il y a on le sait tous une difficulté
forte entre pompiers professionnels et
pompiers volontaires notamment dans la
ruralité à la fois par la libéralisation
du Code du travail sans doute envers ses
pompiers c'est soldats du feu j'ai dû me
battre moi-même en appelant parfois même
les employeurs publics de libérer les
pompiers volontaires pour qu'ils
puissent être en lien avec les feux de
forêt je proposerai bien monsieur le
Président dans discussion avec le
Parlement que nous puissions comme pour
les élus qui sont libérés de leurs
obligations professionnelles d'assister
aux conseils municipal que nous
puissions demander aux employeurs
publics comme privé de libérer en cas de
gestion particulière déclenchée par le
département par le préfet les pompiers
volontaires qui seraient par ailleurs
employés par d'autres personnes mais
c'est aussi le cas évidemment du
financement puisque chacun sait que
lorsqu'il y a des pompiers
professionnels plus nombreux qui parfois
interviennent de façon mieux formée sur
les feux de forêt il coûte également
plus cher au département et donc ainsi
des départements plus riches ou plus
peuplés sont les mieux équipés alors que
le département plus pauvres ou moins
peuplés qui connaissent souvent les plus
de feux de forêt sont les moins bien
équipés donc il y a aussi sans doute une
prééquation à imaginer en tout cas le
réchauffement climatique nous fait poser
des questions d'organisation
d'organisation de notre flotte aérienne
je l'ai dit de nos formices d'ailleurs
de la création des emplois que je
demande les 8500 dans la loi de
programmation il y a une grosse partie
pour la sécurité civile on pourra le
détailler si vous le souhaitez notamment
les formations militaires qui nous
aident à intervenir contre les feux de
forêts très efficace cet été et
également dans le fonctionnement des 10
en rapport avec les pompiers
professionnels volontaires et leur
matériel voilà en quelques mots pour ne
pas être trop long monsieur le Président
et vous dire toute la joie que j'ai de
retrouver la commission des lois pour
cette nouvelle législature en ce qui me
concerne les statut au gouvernementale
merci Monsieur le Ministre peut-être nos
rapporteurs ont-ils le kervé ou monsieur
de Brest
on va pas bouder notre plaisir puisque
vous l'avez dit vous-même vous présentez
une loop me et moi j'ai eu privilège de
présidé la séance de l'Assemblée
nationale il y a 20 ans tout juste ou
Nicolas Sarkozy présentait la loopsie a
et j'ai moi-même présenté une loi de
programmation de la cohésion sociale je
suis donc bien placé pour savoir que le
loi de programmation vous permet quand
même nous permet quand même d'avoir une
perspective à 5 ans qui est une bonne
durée pour un quinquennat par exemple et
permet surtout d'éviter le détricotage
systématique par Bercy l'année suivante
des mesures qui ont été votées l'année
précédente donc
on va pas voter vous vous avez connu
Bercy monsieur Darmanin on va pas bouder
notre plaisir sur l'article 2 sur je
vais reprendre votre chronologie sur le
sur l'article 1 vous avez dit vous-même
que vous aviez par rapport à votre
première mouture supprimée tout ce qui
était lié à l'image et vous savez très
bien que dans vos défis de réussir la
Coupe du monde de rugby et les Jeux
Olympiques il faut une législation qui
aille plus loin sur toute une série de
sujets dont un que le président buffet
nous a demandé de travailler sur la
reconnaissance faciale on a fait avec
Jérôme durat et Arnaud de bellen mission
là-dessus avec des propositions très
concrètes qui s'inspirent d'ailleurs
assez fort de la loi d'expérimentation
sur la loi silk sur le terrorisme est-ce
que vous pouvez nous confirmer qu'il y
aura bien une législation dans le
courant de l'année 2023 et ce que vous
n'êtes pas opposé à ce que cette
législation des échéant prennent la
forme d'une PPL qui pourrait être
coordonnée entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale c'est un sujet important tout
ce qui est traitement de l'image pour
pouvoir réussir les Jeux Olympiques
deuxième question vous avez expliqué
dans dans l'article 2 le doublement de
tout ce qui était présent sur la voie
publique ce matin on recevait les les
plus hauts les plus hautes autorités de
la justice que nous ont confirmés qui ne
voulait rien toucher à la carte
territoriale judiciaire
vous n'en avez pas parlé est-ce que vous
ne touchez pas parce que vous avez
beaucoup parlé à juste titre de la
Gendarmerie et de l'augmentation de la
délinquance en zone rurale à la carte
parce que ça a été un serpent de mer
pendant des années que ce soit Monsieur
Sarkozy monsieur Hortefeu puis les
ministres qui sont succédés sur la sur
la carte police les zones police
gendarmerie est-ce que vous avez on en
parle peu dans le dans le rapport mais
est-ce que vous avez des intentions
là-dessus troisième sujet que vous avez
évoqué je prends dans l'ordre votre de
votre propos
plus de 7 milliards consacrés sur les 15
milliards à la cyber délinquance vous
voulez être le ministre de la cyber
délinquance du 21e siècle comme
Clémenceau a été celui des Brigades du
Tigre du 20e siècle très bien
la question qui se pose c'est quand même
vous le savez vous l'avez évoqué ainsi
d'Amand la jurisprudence européenne et
le fait que
il y a une nouvelle directive qui qui
est en route sur le numérique et que
directive apprenne du directive
finalement on limite les possibilités
d'investigation et notamment le champ
d'investigation des procureurs avec des
préconisations sur la protection des
données est sur la capacité ou pas de
saisir par exemple des fadettes qui ont
fait l'objet encore d'une jurisprudence
d'un cours de cassation au mois de
juillet dernier tout ça pose de grosses
questions d'ailleurs la conférence des
procureurs ne cesse de nous alerter
là-dessus alors vous allez me dire tout
ça ça relève de la justice mais enfin
j'entends bien que nous devons nous
soumettre à législation européenne
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas qu'il faut
quand même avancer sur les questions de
statut des magistrats et de codes de
procédure pénale puisque vous-même vous
vous aventurer sur ce sujet sur la
réforme de la police judiciaire mon
collègue Loïc Hervé vous en parlez et je
termine mon propos pour vous dire que la
FD c'est à dire l'amende forfaitaire
délictuelle nous pose question aussi
puisqu'elle est vous l'avez prévu simple
c'est vrai simple efficace c'est à dire
qu'elle s'appliquerait à tout une série
de délits en dessous d'un canton de
peine est-ce que vous vous pensez qu'il
faut aller jusque là et ce qu'on ne peut
pas mieux serrer les choses sachant que
évidemment dès le moment où on commence
à faire une liste dans une loi on ouvre
la boîte de Pandore de ceux qui veulent
y trouver plus de choses et de ceux qui
veulent y trouver moins de choses voilà
mes questions principales monsieur le
ministre merci Monsieur Hervé merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en complément de ce que Marc
Philippe de Bresse vient de dire d'abord
on va on va saluer la volonté du
gouvernement de commencer le débat
parlementaire par le Sénat c'est
inhabituel sur un texte sécuritaire mais
c'est important pour nous dans la dans
la droite ligne de des textes sécurité
globale puis responsabilité pénale et
sécurité intérieure que voilà on puisse
apporter
notre contribution à cet ouvrage
important qui celui de donner à votre
ministère monsieur le ministre une une
planification une des orientation plus
réelles notamment en matière
d'investissement et ce texte si
l'article premier est le plus dense
puisque il renvoie un rapport
extrêmement
danse touffu
détaillé peut-être que certains de nos
collègues voudront encore plus de
détails du monde sur certains sujets en
tout cas c'est il y a d'autres
dispositions la FD max vient d'en parler
qui concourt un objectif de
déshidiscalisation mais qui nous pose
des interrogations notamment parce que
ce sont des officiers judiciaires qui
sont amenés à les délivrer et que
évidemment il nécessaire qu'elle soit
plus précise moi je reviendrai sur les
questions
des officiers de police judiciaires et
de cette réforme que vous que que vous
voulez faire d'abord en permettant
d'avoir des EPG plus rapidement
opérationnel
en faisant sauter en supprimant un
certain nombre de délai pour les pour
les pour que ces EPG soit efficaces et
deuxièmement de de
créer auprès d'eux ce qu'on appelle des
assistants d'enquête personnelles qui
sont qui devrait être recrutés en
plusieurs par plusieurs milliers 3000
4000 et qui seraient amenés à faire en
sorte que les OPJ fassent leur boulot
d'opéji quand ces assistants d'enquêtres
feraient un travail je vois les
guillemets de de greffier d'OPJ auprès
d'eux pour évidemment alléger la charge
administrative c'est le temps d'enquête
ce sont des gens qui doivent être formés
former à binicio
formé ensuite pour être opérationnel
auprès des OPJ dans un contexte dans
lequel c'est vrai que
il y a une forme de désaffection pour le
pour la carrière de l'enquête et donc ma
question plus précise et ce sera
d'ailleurs la seule c'est comment est-ce
que vous voyez
comment est-ce que vous voyez qu'on
puisse rendre ces métiers attirants sur
un plan statutaire sur un plan de la
formation et puis sur un plan aussi
professionnel parce que le métier qu'on
va leur confier ne peut pas être
simplement le fait de faire les tâches
rébarbatives que les autres pays JPG ne
voudraient plus faire on va on va
améliorer la situation mais il faut
qu'on arrive à trouver des personnels
qui soient intéressés par cette par
cette nouvelle mission merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur l'avoir madame Dumont sur
la spéc sécurité civile oui merci
monsieur le Président
et Madame Laurent saribet monsieur le
ministre je suis ravie de la deuxième
partie de cette audition qu'elle soit
consacrée à l'état et aux moyens de la
sécurité civile dont l'action a été au
coeur et effectivement vous l'avez
précisé d'un été malheureusement
exceptionnel sur le front des incendies
et nous rendons comme vous l'avez fait
hommage à l'ensemble des forces de
sécurité civile sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels volontaire
personnelle administratif et techniques
et généralement tous ceux qui ont prêté
main forte pour venir à bout de ces
terribles incendies l'été que nous
venons de vivre à rappeler s'il en était
encore besoin la nécessité pour notre
pays de disposer d'une force
d'intervention à la hauteur des risques
qui semblent désormais à les croissants
d'après les données du système européen
d'information sur les feux de forêt à la
mi-septembre se sont en effet 65000
hectares qui ont brûlé cette année en
France cela représente une
multiplication par 7 par rapport à la
moyenne des 15 dernières années qui se
situe légèrement au des 9000 hectares il
s'agit de très loin de la plus grande
surface brûlée depuis que nous disposons
de donner consolidées à l'échelle
européenne soit 2006 et encore la saison
des feux n'est pas arrivé à sa fin comme
l'ont montré les récents incendies de
somos et de Sainte-Hélène en Gironde
fait inquiétant et inhabituel ces
incendies vous l'avez aussi précisé ont
touché la majeure partie de notre
territoire national la Bretagne ou les
massifs du Jura des Vosges
d'ordinaire et épargnés ont été
également victimes de vastes incendies
estivaux et nous avons eu si je puis
dire de la chance que la bande
méditerranéenne n'est pas connue de
grands feux en même temps car à
l'évidence les moyens auraient été
insuffisants il faut tirer de ces
événements un bilan et des perspectives
afin que la France soit mieux armée pour
faire face à des conditions
météorologiques qui devraient devenir la
norme dans un futur proche
il est certain que face à des risques
accrus et à une fréquence plus élevée de
feuilles extrêmes ou mégafeux nos
capacités de prévention et de lutte
contre les incendies doivent être
adaptés en nombre et en type de moyens à
ce titre nous avons bien entendu les
propos du président de la République qui
a déclaré lors de son déplacement à test
de bûche que la France devait désormais
avoir davantage de moyens aériens dédiés
à la lutte contre les incendies en
achetant plus de Canadair mais au niveau
européen nous attendons néanmoins des
précisions quant à cet engagement en
termes de calendrier notamment renvoyer
uniquement vers une réponse européenne
ne peut bien évidemment pas suffire
comme la d'ailleurs montrer la
simultanéité des violents incendies de
cet été en Espagne au Portugal et en
France l'examen dans les prochaines
semaines de la locmi dans l'un des
volets budgétaires concernent les moyens
alloués à la flotte aérienne de la
sécurité civile semble donc complètement
à propos
avant cela dans le premier élément de
bilan sur lequel je souhaiterais vous
interroger concerne les moyens humains
et matériels qui ont été touchés au
cours des actions de lutte contre les
incendies des décès je crois que vous
avez dit que non ou des blessés graves
ont-ils été recensé parmi nos
sapeurs-pompiers mobilisés disposez-vous
d'éléments chiffrés sur les pertes
matérielles qui sont sont suivies quel
coûtent représentera leur remplacement
pour les 10 qui en ont la charge la
flotte aérienne qui dépend de l'état
a-t-elle subi des dommages lors des
interventions plus globalement quel
bilan tirez-vous de cette saison
éprouvante qu'elles ont été les éléments
de satisfaction à l'inverse les
dysfonctionnements que vous avez pu
identifier quelles réponses
prévoyez-vous d'apporter à ces derniers
en ce qui concerne les perspectives pour
les années futures à travers
l'accroissement des moyens aériens tels
qu'anoncés par le Président de la
République et dans le rapport annexé à
la locmi nous souhaiterions des
précisons
décision quant à l'ampleur qui nous est
présenté en effet la locmi annonce un
objectif de remplacement en 5 ans des
hélicoptères vieillissants du ministère
de l'Intérieur investissement qui
concernerait au total 36 appareils dans
quelle mesure les hélicoptères affectés
à la lutte contre les incendies font
partie de ce lot des 36 appareils quels
sont les critères pour définir un
hélicoptère comme vieillissant par
ailleurs les quatre nouveaux appareils
annoncés en 2020 et 2021 ont-ils été
livrés et dans le cas contraire sont-ils
inclus dans cette annonce de 36 nouveaux
hélicoptères concernant les avions
bombardiers d'eau amphibie vous prévoyez
d'augmenter la flotte de Canadair de 12
à 16 dont 2 dans le cadre du programme
rescue déjà programmé depuis 2020 tout
en annonçant un renouvellement de la
flotte de 12 avions cl415 dont nous
sommes déjà équipés
pouvez-vous nous confirmer qu'il s'agit
bien de remplacer l'ensemble de la
flotte des Canadairs y compris les plus
récents et nous préciser le coût de
Saint investissement que nous imaginons
particulièrement significatifs quels
sont les attentes du ministère en termes
d'innovation et de capacités des
nouveaux appareils et enfin
prévoyez-vous de profiter du marché
européen rescue d'acquisition de
Canadair pour en acquérir sur des moyens
nationaux à l'instar de ce que fait la
Grèce à raison de 5 et l'Espagne qui
vont d'ailleurs les financer sur des
fonds européens enfin dans ce contexte
de mobilisation des services de secours
il semble opportun de mettre en
perspective les avancées de la loi dite
matras que nous avons voté il y a un peu
moins d'un an et sa mise en oeuvre ou
non au cours de l'été la loi matras a
notamment autorisé le lancement d'une
expérimentation d'un numéro unique
d'appel d'urgence pour une période de
deux ans or un autre connaissance
expérimentation n'a toujours pas été
initié la période que nous avons connue
cet été pendant laquelle les services de
secours ont fait l'objet d'une forte
sollicitation aurait pourtant été
propice à un retour d'expérience
particulièrement enrichissant
pouvez-vous nous indiquer quel est le
nouveau calendrier de votre ministère
pour donner suite à cette mesure votée
par le Parlement il y a désormais
presque un an et je vous remercie merci
madame Monsieur Henri le roi
oui monsieur le Président merci Monsieur
monsieur le ministre je voudrais juste
compléter l'une des questions du
rapporteur parce que quand on regarde le
rapport qui est annexé sur la
modernisation du ministère de
l'intérieur lorsque on examine l'exposé
des motifs effectivement on y retrouve
l'ensemble de la trame des travaux qui
ont été annoncés par le livre blanc et
qui ont fait l'objet pendant plusieurs
mois de travaux ministères de
l'Intérieur dans ce qu'on a appelé le
bobo de la sécurité
j'avais cru comprendre
durant ces mois de d'échange que vous
aviez placé comme un des axes d'efforts
le redécoupage territorial en notre
police et gendarmerie que vous aviez
testé d'ailleurs à Toulouse et qui avait
suscité de vivre et actions des élus
mais il est évident que et vous le
commencez en tout cas vous le débutez
vous débutez cette réforme par quelque
chose qui
est approuvé par tous ceux qui ont
exercé un pouvoir important dans les
forces de police c'est effectivement la
départementalisation où il y a un chef
des moyens d'émissions mais en tout cas
sous la responsabilité d'un seul et
unique chef ma question est très simple
pour compléter est-ce que ce redécoupage
territorial entre les forces de sécurité
et désormais abandonné alors que ça a
été l'un de vos axes forts à juste titre
me semble-t-il à très juste titre car
c'est peut-être que là
c'est peut-être là que se situe la
véritable réforme territoriale ou est-ce
que vous la différé mais en tout cas
elle n'apparaît plus comme étant un de
vos axes d'efforts merci merci Monsieur
Leroy madame Marie B
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vais essayer de compléter
les remarques de Françoise Dumont notre
rapporteur vous êtes venus en Gironde
vous avez accompagné le président de la
République et j'étais là au moment où
vous étiez là
il vous a été présenté un certain nombre
de requêtes par le président du
Département Jean-Luc glaise associé au
président des Landes il y avait très
clairement trois demandes très précises
d'abord que les incendies avaient montré
la limite du financement
est-ce que vous pouvez en dire un peu
plus parce qu'il faut revoir la
législation actuelle
deuxièmement la coordination des forces
nationales et européennes mais là je
vais pas aller plus loin parce que je
crois que Françoise Dumont a été
suffisamment clair là-dessus et le
troisième élément qui est le plus
important il me semble c'est que en fait
il a été demander un renforcement de la
Force aérienne nationale mais surtout de
la localisation
sur des grandes zones en France et pas
une seule localisation à Nîmes or quand
on lit le projet la présentation du
projet de loi de programmation on se
rend compte en fait qu'on reste sur une
localisation unique alors que on a bien
vu que ça posait problème d'autant plus
avec la doctrine du feu naissant qui
oblige donc à réagir très très vite et
il serait important d'avoir un
quadrillage territorial il faut pas en
avoir dans tous les départements mais au
moins trois quatre zones qui sont
sujettes à des incendies simplement vous
faire une remarque aussi parce que je
peux pas laisser passer ça monsieur le
mini si vous me le permettez la forêt
gérondine n'est pas une forêt qui n'est
pas entretenue puisque c'est une forêt
alors vous faisiez peut-être référence à
la forêt de La Teste qui est une forêt
usagère mais la tête c'est une petite
partie de ce qui a brûlé tout le reste
c'est de la forêt la production et qui
est largement entretenu et si on n'a pas
eu de feu depuis 76 là-bas c'est bien
parce que il y avait réellement un
entretien de cette forêt et en effet
vous avez raison de souligner que les
conditions météo climatiques font qu'on
est dans une fournaise et qu'il suffit
qu'il y ait une étincelle pour qu'en
effet ça flambe mais on aurait eu
beaucoup plus de dégâts s'il y avait pas
eu les pistes forestières et l'entretien
par les sylviculteurs et les services
départementaux d'incendie je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie pour votre
intervention
et je voulais poser deux questions la
loi 3DS définitivement adoptée en
février de 1022 abordé déjà les sujets
de la décentralisation et de la
simplification de l'action publique
aujourd'hui vous souhaitez à l'issue de
ce nouveau projet de loi relocaliser des
services centraux du ministère de
l'Intérieur en Provence afin de réduire
les inégalités d'accès au service public
comment comptez-vous concrètement et
mettre en place cette décentralisation
dans quel délai et quelles sont les
villes qui accueilleront vos services
décentralisés
et je termine concernant l'accueil des
victimes vous dites qu'on pourra
désormais porter plainte et être entendu
par visio est-ce que cela remplacera le
procès-verbal comment assurer la
confidentialité de ces enregistrements
visio je vous remercie merci Madame et
puis pour terminer cette première série
Monsieur Philippe Bonnecarrère
oui merci monsieur le Président de
donner la parole même si cela devient un
exercice vraiment marathon pour monsieur
le ministre
je ne reviens pas sur les articans et
deux qui sont bien sûr très importants
regardez ambitions exprimé et je n'irai
pas sur les terrains très techniques qui
ont été adoptés
très structuré par mes collègues qui
sont intervenus précédemment je voudrais
vous interroger plus sur le ce que
j'appellerai le tulage dans la relation
avec les autres ministère en lisant les
documents j'étais frappés
premièrement par la question de ce que
j'appellerais le culage ou la relation
avec le ministère de la Justice j'avoue
que je ne m'attendais pas à trouver dans
la lobe me des dispositions qui sont
très clairement des dispositions de
procédures pénales
ou pénale on ne cesse de nous dire et
l'exercice a été fait ce matin dans le
cadre du rendu des états généraux de la
justice que les questions de procédure
pénal et doit être vu de manière
systémique et surtout pas par des
réformes partielles et là on voit un
certain nombre de mesures dont sur
lesquels je n'ai pas forcément d'avis
particuliers mais pourquoi allez-vous
sur ce terrain pénal et si vous y allez
je n'ai presque dire alors c'est trop
peu ou trop puisque si vous y allez la
question de shadowbresse posé sur les
moyens ce qu'on appelle les techniques
spéciales d'investigation avec la
question de la définition de la
criminalité grave pour se poser en
résumé comment tuer les vous quelque
part votre texte avec les projets du
avec le garde des sceaux deuxièmement
dans pas dans le projet de loi lui-même
mais dans le rapport annexé il y a une
partie très
consacrée à l'informatique on perçoit
que vous-même et votre ministère avait
l'ambition de vous positionner en
producteur de solutions informatiques ce
qui peut se comprendre et qui est la
faiblesse de certains de vos voisins je
pense en particulier au domaine de la
justice dont de notoriété publique les
procédures informatiques sont
insuffisantes comment vous le savez
est-ce que c'est un choix fichier de
votre part de vouloir faire de votre
ministère la dorsale d'une sorte de
restructuration numérique
des ministères régaliens prenant
peut-être un peu le relais de ce qui
avait été l'émission antérieurement de
madame manchalin qui avait un petit peu
cette fonction transversale et je
termine ma questionnement sur les
relations avec les autres membres du
gouvernement du moins avec les autres
actions gouvernementales avec les
relations avec le ministère de la
Défense vous avez bien sûr le
pour des comptes comme chacun sait à
poser des questions sur l'opération
sentinelle je peux comprendre que vous
souhaitiez monsieur le ministre et
garder toutes vos forces en termes
d'ordre public dans la perspective à
coup de monde du rugby mais surtout des
Jeux olympiques de 2024 mais après 2024
même si c'est moyen vous êtes bien
chacun de nous est conscient au-delà
même de l'actualité de ce jour quant au
fait quand même que notre pays a de
solide sujet de défense de solide sujet
géopolitique et d'une certaine manière
une opération comme sentinelle ne pourra
pas continuer éternellement si on veut
que le ministère de la Défense puisse
s'assurer complètement sa mission merci
de vos éléments de réponse sur ces
relations avec les autres ministères et
sur la trajectoire que vous souhaitez
mettre merci Monsieur benkaer la parole
au ministre pour une première série de
réponses il reste encore six questions à
suivre
merci monsieur le Président commençons
par le commencement monsieur le ministre
de Bresse oui je vous confirme que notre
volonté est notre devoir c'est d'avoir
des dispositions relatifs aux images au
statut de l'image dans un texte de loi
qui soit d'origine gouvernementale j'ai
évoqué le projet de loi Jeux Olympiques
qui soit d'origine parlementaire si
vous-même ou l'Assemblée nationale
venait à déposer une proposition de loi
évidemment indépendamment de du droit
profond des parlementaires à proposer la
loi nous l'accompagnerions avec avec
intérêt c'est un devoir parce que
d'abord nous avons des injonctions vous
le savez de la part de la CNIL et du
Conseil d'État pour fondre dans un
statut de statut de l'image et pour que
au moins les caméras de lit de
protection de nos communes puis cette
conforme aux prescriptions du rgpd
donc d'abord il faut le faire parce que
le Conseil d'État avec nous le demande
ensuite parce qu'on en a besoin et je
pense notamment à l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle qui faisait
partie du dossier de candidature de
Paris et du gouvernement d'alors aux
Jeux Olympiques donc on doit pouvoir
répondre au CIO de ces demandes
d'utilisation d'intelligence
artificielle dans les caméras de vie de
protection dans le traitement et comme
vous-même puisque j'ai lu avec attention
votre rapport moi je suis opposé la
reconnaissance faciale qui n'est
évidemment pas mais vous êtes des
spécialistes de l'intelligence
artificielle de la biométrie et de ce
point de vue il faut aussi qu'on le dise
on le droit français qu'est-ce qu'on
veut faire avec l'image et l'image de
demain donc je crois qu'on peut trouver
un compromis qui sera forcément
difficile parce qu'il s'agit de ici
regarder liberté et sécurité
comment on peut résister
la tentation de ne pas avancer sur ce
sujet essentiel je vais dire derrière
l'intention de la commission des lois
que pendant un an et demi on a parlé des
drones on a eu beaucoup d'échanges sur
les drones à la fin des fins
la solution est quand même un peu
étonnante puisque le minisateur peut
faire donc voler des drones en
renseignement mais il peut pas le faire
en judiciaire
on lui a interdit il me semblait que
c'était dans le discours général que le
judiciaire était plus protecteur des
libertés que le préfet mais je comprends
que la sagesse du Parlement et du
Conseil professionnel a donc laissé au
préfet le soin des plus protecteur des
libertés que juge qui laissait autoriser
le fonctionnement de ces drones et donc
parfois on rentre dans un débat on sait
pas très bien qu'on en sort je vais pas
me plaindre à ce que désormais à décrire
va bientôt sortir Isra évidemment
envoyer au Parlement et notamment
rapporteur qui ont beaucoup travaillé
sur cette question et je pense notamment
aux rapporteur Hervé que on peut faire
voler des drones renseignements et pas
aux judiciaire donc ça tue d'image va
nous réserver des moments sans doute
étonnants dans les discussions
parlementaires et juridique le deuxième
sujet on évoqué celui mais c'est le cas
du sénateur Leroy des zones de police et
le gendarmerie il est vrai que dans le
livre blanc
livre blanc qui a été commandé par mon
prédécesseur et que j'ai réceptionné
puisque je suis devenu ministre au
moment où il a été rendu il y avait un
gros axe de transformation des zones et
des autres gendarmerie bon c'est vrai
que ça ça déballe que tout le monde aime
depuis au moins 50 sur le territoire
national
l'herbe est parfois plus verte
qu'ailleurs ceux qui ont des gendarmes
veulent des policiers et ceux qui a des
policiers veulent parfois des gendarmes
et ça pose beaucoup de difficultés parce
que c'est beaucoup d'argent parce que
les gendarmes chacun de ces vivent
souvent dans leur caserne il faut donc
pouvoir loger des familles construire
des casernes accompagner leur vie de
famille et les policiers de vivent pas
là où ils travaillent en tout cas
souvent en tout cas pas dans le
commissariat à coup sûr et donc il y a
beaucoup de transformations RH beaucoup
de transformation avec les collectivités
locales de deux coups et moi il ne m'a
pas paru évident que cette disposition
soit l'énergie qu'on doit mettre à 2 ans
des Jeux Olympiques sur le territoire
national il peut y avoir ici ou là des
exceptions je pense notamment des
territoires ultramarins qui font des
demandes parce que la population a
beaucoup augmenté ou sur certains
territoires de la métropole mais je les
ai pour l'instant tous refusés mais ne
pas voir le grand soir des zones polices
et des zones gendarmerie d'abord c'est
c'est j'ai pas besoin de la loi pour ça
puisque je crois que dans le Code
général des collectivités et dans le de
la sécurité intérieure la seule
disposition qui prévoit zone police et
gendarmerie c'est de taquer à 30000
habitants pour le reste nous pouvons
imaginer de le faire sans consulter le
Parlement non moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est c'est de constater je sais pas si
tous les commissaires aux lois le savent
qu'il n'y a pas de disposition légale
qui empêche les gendarmes d'aller en
zone police et policiers d'aller en zone
gendarmerie et moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que ces zones n'existent pas
vraiment je prends trois exemples
d'abord 80% désormais les escadrons de
gendarmerie mobile intervient dans une
police quand les gendarmes mobiles je
les ai mis j'ai mis un escargot de
gendarmerie mobile à des exposition du
préfet de Perpignan bon bah dans
Perpignan et aujourd'hui un esclavage
gendarmerie mobile qui travaille quand
ils sont monsieur le ministre Richard
dans le Val-d'Oise il y a beaucoup de
gendarmes dans le Val-d'Oise aussi
beaucoup de policiers il y a beaucoup de
gendarmes Valoises qui interviennent en
mobile dans les coins police du
Val-d'Oise donc d'abord les mobiles
peuvent aller dans les zones police ce
gendarmerie on pourrait dessérès aux
zones gendarmerie des gendarmes mobiles
en zone police pas besoin de changer la
loi de bouger les casernes par
définition ils sont mobiles deuxièmement
pour les Jeux Olympiques je vais
proposer j'aurais l'occasion d'en
reparler devant la commission des lois
puisque le président souhaite que je
vais expliciter notre travaux sécurité
je vais demander un peu à la communion
de rugby et beaucoup aux Jeux Olympiques
que pendant ce temps très particulier
des trois mois des Jeux Olympiques on va
pouvoir dire à des gendarmes d'aller
dans une police ou alors dire aux
gendarmes par exemple du Calvados toute
façon temporaire de s'occuper du
commissariat de Lisieux pendant que les
agents de police nationale viennent en
Seine-Saint-Denis pour aider leur
camarades devant l'afflux de spectateurs
et contre la délinquance j'ai pas
d'annonce à faire aux gens du
commissariat de Lisieux j'entends d'ici
les tracts syndicaux je veux dire que je
veux dire que
on ne verra que ce qu'on croit bon
monsieur le sénateur mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que je n'ai pas besoin de la
loi pour demander au policier aux
gendarmes d'aller dans des endroits qui
sont polis ce gendarmerie c'est
tellement vrai que le préfet de
Alpes-Maritimes comme la préfète de
police des Bouches-du-Rhône Amanda de
psy lors des départements les aider lors
des matchs de football donc je veux dire
au commissaire lois que je n'ai pas
besoin de changer les lieux
géographiques de zone pour pouvoir les
faire travailler ensemble et
troisièmement pour répondre totalement
monsieur Leroy l'exemple qu'il a pris de
Toulouse est le bon exemple Toulouse
prend 10 000 habitants minimum par an la
connurbation Toulousaine est vraiment
ses actes de transport ont suivi la
métropole qui a grandi et les transports
qui sont des lieux criminogènes
importants sont coupés entre zone police
ces zones gendarmerie et quand on veut
faire le tram ou le bus sécurisé le tram
le bus de de Toulouse parfois le
policier s'arrête descend du du du bus
et puis normalement la gendarmerie
devrait prendre la suite bon c'est
absurde rien ne ne sait pas la police
municipale de Lambersart Monsieur le
Maire et de Lille on s'arrête pas aux
frontières des communes pour la police
municipale les gendarmes et policiers
ils ont à droite suite sur le territoire
national et donc ce que je préfère faire
c'est plutôt que de penser en territoire
comme on pensait il y a 50 ans police et
gendarmerie pensez en zone de
délinquance il y a aujourd'hui des
endroits où les changeurs d'autoroute
étant zone police et l'autoroute est en
zone gendarmerie et on fait des
contrôles routiers des contrôles en
répartissant deux types de compétences
il faut faire des réunions pour savoir
quasiment qui doit intervenir c'est
pareil pour la ligne de bus je vais
changer les choses par la direction
unique des transports de lutte contre la
sécurité dans les transports on va
donner des axes à des policiers ou à des
gendarmes plutôt que penser à des
territoires je sais pas si j'ai pas fait
bien comprendre et ça me paraît plus
intelligent que dépenser beaucoup
d'argent dans les collectivités locales
pour changer la brigade de gendarmerie
pour savoir si elle doit quitter
La Bassée pour aller pour aller ailleurs
voilà donc je n'oublie pas la
transformation et la mutualisation de
police et gendarmerie
je pense que j'en ai tiré une conclusion
différente c'est une proposition je n'ai
pas retenu du Livre blanc en le faisant
travailler plus sur la délinquance que
sur la zone territoriale troisième
c'était bien ça dont vous posez comme
question monsieur le sénateur
et ben j'en suis j'en suis très heureux
troisième sujet la question des données
et de la jurisprudence européenne
effectivement je ne peux que vous
répondre que il a il est à coup sûr de
la compétence totale de monsieur le
garde des sceaux pour résumer il s'agit
désormais de faire que les procureurs de
la République ne peuvent plus utiliser
un certain nombre de données
téléphoniques notamment ce que vous
appelez les fadettes en langage policier
bon langage magistrat et que seul le
juge peut le demander évidemment ça
inquiète beaucoup non seulement les
procureurs mais les policiers et les
gendarmes les services enquêteurs
également je crois que monsieur le garde
des sceaux travaille sur cette question
dans le cadre notamment d'un texte de
loi je l'attends avec impatience comme
tous les services de police et de
gendarmerie autant que les procure la
République parce que si on ne peut pas
utiliser les données alors ça va devenir
très compliqué je rappelle que déjà les
écoutes téléphoniques ont un rendement
assez décroissant puisque plus personne
quasiment de téléphone en ligne normale
puisque tout le monde passe par WhatsApp
par télégram par facebook Messenger et
que sais encore et que vous n'avez
autorisé vous le Parlement que dans un
cadre antiterroriste d'utiliser des
moyens technologiques pour surveiller
les téléphones et les données parce que
la Sûreté nationale c'est plus important
que tout mais je n'ai pas le droit avec
les services qui sont sur mon autorité
te demander des écoutes technologiques
ou téléphoniques dans la grande
criminalité je sais pas le droit de le
faire sur un grand trafic de stup si je
pouvais regarder WhatsApp télégram et
signal il reste sans doute moins de
domicile à Marseille du règlement de
compte mais je fais avec ce que me donne
évidemment le Parlement ça pose
évidemment d'autres questions de liberté
publique alors si en plus de ce contenu
qu'on n'a pas le droit de voir on n'a
pas le droit aux données de localisation
par exemple ou d'appel ça va devenir
extrêmement compliqué pour un service
enquêteur donc il appartiendra monsieur
le garde des sceaux sont de trouver les
voies et les moyens pour permettre au
procure la République au service
enquêteur de pouvoir continuer à faire
des enquêtes sans alourdir la procédure
avec un juge d'instruction unique mais
évidemment comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même il y a les décisions
européennes qui s'imposent à nous et
donc il faut que nous discutions ce
point et je suis à la fois soulagé et
heureux que ce soit de regarder ceux qui
va trouver la solution
le troisième
quatrième sujet pardon pour vous avez
posé celui des AFD et finalement vous
avez dit c'est une disposition
importante peut-être que vous pensez
aussi à ça monsieur le sénateur bonne
Carrère nous on dit voilà toute
condamnation d'un an et d'un mois d'un
an de prison on fait une amende
forfaitaire de rituel évidemment
toujours sous l'autorité du procureur de
la République puisque c'est lui qui
parle circulaire pénal explique comment
on applique tel ou tel AFD d'abord je
voudrais vous dire que lorsqu'on a
discuté des AFD notamment tissu il y a
eu beaucoup de
suspicions pour dire à ce que ça va
marcher c'est avant de forfaitaire de
rituel être par recouverte lavande
est-ce que comment trouver l'identité
des personnes quand on a fait sur les
consommateurs qui est finalement la
première AFD que je vous ai proposé elle
marche extrêmement bien 225000 amfd ont
été dressés depuis septembre 2020 et on
a mieux condamné 30% de sanctions en
plus la consommation de drogue dans
notre pays
donc les invité c'est pas la pâte assez
atout mais ça permet au service de
police et de gendarmerie dans une
simplification pénale puisque ce sont
eux qui mettent la sanction sans passer
par le procureur de la République sans
passer par la justice mais avec
l'autorisation et la couverture si j'ose
dire de la justice d'inscrire otages une
amende pénale qui parieur désormais à
l'avant du président de la République
sera recouverte automatiquement sur les
comptes en banque des impétrants et la
lived elle est mieux recouvertes que la
l'amande que l'on met désormais sur la
route donc ça montre l'efficacité du
système alors nous on veut généraliser
la FD pourquoi parce que chacun sait que
lorsque qu'on commet des petits délits
et après tout la consommation de drogue
sur la voie publique c'était un petit
délit c'est pas pareil que d'être dealer
de drogue bien évidemment mais quand on
fait un tag quand on insulte un voisin
lorsque on fait de un certain nombre de
dégradations de l'espace public qui sont
très rarement condamnés ou très rarement
poursuivi il y a un sentiment d'impunité
chez nos concitoyens de dire il y a même
pas de le policier qui va interpeller
quelqu'un pour un tag il y a peu de
chances pour que sa procédure aille
jusqu'au bout parce que pour qu'on a la
République à la fin dira un rappel à la
loi c'est-à-dire pas de réponse pénale
et sorte de d'encouragement à la planité
et donc nous nous pensons qu'il vaut
mieux simplifier à sa tombe de procédure
pénale pour qu'il y ait une sanction
financière une inscription au casier
judiciaire et la FD prévoit bien que
s'il y a récidive ce n'est plus l'AFD
mais une sanction pénale plus lourde
donc ça nous paraît être une bonne
mesure cependant nous avons bien compris
que le Conseil d'État avait décidé de
disjoindre sa disposition du projet de
loi que nous avons proposé j'ai fait
quand même le choix j'en remercie le
Conseil des ministres de l'avoir accepté
de le maintenir pour que le Parlement
comprenne quelle est la volonté de
l'exécutif et donc je dis au rapporteur
que s'il trouve une écriture juridique
efficace ce qui est le cas du Sénat
monsieur le Président à chaque à chaque
à chaque disposition et si vous trouvez
un amendement qui changerait cet article
qui garderait la philosophie de cette
simplification procédure pour les
policiers et les gendarmes tout en ça
peut être la liste ça peut des critères
je ne sais pas faut qu'on y travaille
avec la commission des lois nous serons
très ouverts à porter non seulement dans
les mystique du Sénat mais aussi à
l'Assemblée nationale ces dispositions
le mieux étant que nous puissions
trouver quelque chose qui veulent comme
on dit dans les discussions à un moment
test Monsieur Hervé ma première question
à des assistants d'enquêtes là aussi
c'est un point très important quel est
le problème de la police et de la de la
gendarmerie c'est que nous n'avons pas
nous policiers gendarmes permettez-moi
de ma dans leur travail
le même distinction qu'il y a dans la
justice entre le spécialiste du droit
qui est le juge d'instruction par
exemple et le greffier quel est le
spécialiste du formalisme et on sait
tous qu'une bonne partie des procédures
pénales tombe parfois quand les
procédures de police et de gendarmerie
sont mal faites parce que la forme n'est
pas forcément bien faite et c'est normal
d'ailleurs que cette procédure tombe moi
je me tue si je veux dire à dire au
policier aux que lorsqu'une sanction
pénale ne correspond pas à l'envie que
l'analyse du fait par le policier
gendarme tombe c'est pas toujours à
cause du magistrat c'est parfois qu'on a
mal fait la procédure donc il y a une
question de formation et une question
évidemment de d'efficacité des chefs à
regarder les procédures mais aussi le
fait que les policiers jambes font tout
ils accueillent le garder à vue ils
appellent l'avocat ils appellent le
médecin il lui fournissent le repas ils
font les photocopies nous on fait des
procédures numériques parfois il faut
imprimer les poissons numériques parce
que justement le tribunal lui n'a pas la
procédure numérique donc il faut rien
imprimer tout ce que les policiers ont
fait en numérique bref ils perdent
énormément de temps en formalisme
nécessaire pour la procédure mais non
essentielle au travail de l'enquêteur et
ça déprime les EPJ que de voir que leur
travail n'est pas un travail
essentiellement de recherche de la
vérité mais après de 12 voilà et donc
nous on pense que en créant ces
assistants d'enquête que seul notre
volonté de ne pas embêter vérifier nous
a empêché de l'appeler greffier de
police mais c'est le principe que les
assistants d'enquête qui viennent du
personnel administratif technique et
scientifiques de la maison ministère de
l'Intérieur Monsieur Hervé vous parliez
de qui était ces gens c'est déjà des
gens qui existent c'est du personnel
administratif puisse faire ce formalisme
s'occuper du repas appelé le médecin
répondre à la question de l'avocat qui
est présent dès la première de garde à
vue permettent de passer l'appel auquel
on a le droit faire des photocopies et
peut-être être en contact avec le
greffier justement de la de la maison de
la de la du cabinet de gestion par
exemple juste à côté va libérer du temps
enquêteur pour pouvoir se concentrer sur
le travail d'enquêteur donc c'est
vraiment une disposition extrêmement
importante alors évidemment il faut bien
les former il faut évidemment si on veut
leur donner des des petits pouvoirs
judiciaires type APJ il faut les
habiliter il faut évidemment définir
leur rôle mais je pense que c'est là
c'est une révolution très importante du
ministère de l'Intérieur pour libérer du
temps enquêteur et pour justement
permettre aux enquêteurs de choisir
cette voie et qui ne passe pas 50% de
leur temps en formalisme et seulement
50% de temps en enquête et donc nous
sommes tout à fait prêt monsieur le
rapporteur à imaginer de de définir
mieux ces assistants d'enquêtes alors
pour la police ce serait personnel
administratif technique et scientifique
pour la gendarmerie ce sera soit du
personnel civil militaire soit du
personnel civile tout court et donc on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler on a à peu
près calculer mais c'est un peu
technocratique que pour un au PJ la
création de ces enquêtes permet de
libérer 0,5 équivalent en plein
imaginons que ce soit que 0,2 03 on voit
bien que dans chaque commissariat ça
veut dire quand même évidemment des
postes madame peut-être de terminer par
la sécurité puis je reviendrai sur la
sécurité civile si vous en êtes si vous
en êtes d'accord bon je crois que j'ai
répondu à Monsieur Leroy et je vais
répondre donc à Monsieur van Carrère sur
la question de finalement vous faites un
peu du judiciaire alors que c'est un
test un texte sécurité bon d'abord j'ai
exactement la question inverse d'hier à
la semelle donc ça c'est toujours
amusant puisqu'il y a on va reprocher de
pas faire un texte avec plus de justice
donc
je voudrais pas
je regarde ça de loin mais
ce que nous avons fait monsieur bonne
Carrère c'est que nous avons décidé en
étable extérieur et donc avec le garde
des sceaux que tout ce qui relevait une
procédure pénale simplifiée à hauteur de
policiers et de gendarmes
c'est à dire non en lien direct avec un
magistrat mérité d'être dans le texte
que je propose il y a des
simplifications
conclus dans le bobo de la sécurité
auquel le président de la République a
demandé qu'elle soit dans son acte
puisque c'est dans son discours de Nice
qui est par exemple la fusion du cadre
d'enquête entre l'enquête préliminaire
et l'enquête de flagrance qui sera aussi
une énorme avancée pour les services de
police qui ont deux types d'enquêtes
quand tu as fait arrivent bon sera porté
par le garde des sceaux dans son texte
justice donc vous voyez il y a ce qui
relève
la FD ça me paraît une procédure à
hauteur d'homme policier au gendarmes ou
être de femmes policiers gendarmes alors
que la fusion des cadres enquêtes c'est
évidemment un sujet plus justice vous
remarquerez d'ailleurs que dans mon
texte si j'ose dire mon texte il n'y a
pas de sanction pénale alourdi donc on
change pas le code pénal ça il
appartient évidemment au Garde des sauts
de pouvoir proposer un certain nombre de
changement s'il avait envie de proposer
des changements donc oui il y a des
entrées dans la procédure judiciaire
mais ce travail du policier du gendarme
écrit par nature à part les
renseignements territoriaux agissent
sous l'autorité du procureur de la
République ou la magistrat donc ça ne me
paraît pas totalement un texte justice
c'est moins qu'on puisse dire sur
l'informatique en tout cas sur le cyber
et numérique vous avez raison de dire
que ma volonté c'est de transformer mes
intérieur que j'ai vu comme étant très
courageux par ces femmes et ses hommes
très mobilisés sur les crises très
efficace dans beaucoup de domaines mais
très en retard dans la technologie dans
le cyber en retard vis-à-vis de la
délinquance aujourd'hui donc le
Clémenceau 2.0 évoqué par marfield de
Bresse ce café Clémenceau il a constaté
le changement de la criminalité et il a
donc dit aux gens il fallait au
policiers il faut vous organiser parce
qu'une communauté organisée c'est pour
ça qu'elle est Brigades du Tigre on va
donc faire nous des Brigades du Tigre
numérique qui ne sont pas des tigres de
papier par nature mais des tigres
d'écran bon le deuxième sujet c'est
quand même de pouvoir améliorer notre
lien avec la population
le but du jeu c'est pas de garder des
policiers dans des commissariats moi je
souhaite qu'il passe moins de temps
possible dans les commissariats et que
les personnes n'aient même plus au
commissariat pour déposer plainte il y a
une disposition révolutionnaire dans ce
texte qui prévoit de faire des plaintes
numériques par visio aujourd'hui les
gens prennent demi-journée de congés
pour aller déposer plainte ils attendent
longtemps c'est pas toujours propre ils
sont parfois mal reçus on a beaucoup de
d'améliorations à faire pour être un bon
service public d'accueil parce que ceux
qui vont à la police c'est pas que les
gens qui vont garder à vue c'est tous
les concitoyens qui déposent une plainte
et vous savez tous que il y a plein
d'expériences où on refuse d'autres
plainte c'est compliqué c'est long c'est
moche les affiches tombent un peu le
commissariat est pas très beau bon ça
peut arriver que l'image de la police
nationale ou la brigade de Jean-Marie
soit pas très bonne et on comprend pas
pourquoi aujourd'hui on peut se on peut
quasiment faire toutes ces démarches sur
Internet sauf dans la police nationale
gendarmerie nationale alors c'est
exactement le même problème qu'il y a 5
ans lorsque je suis arrivé au ministère
des comptes publics puisque nous avons
fait l'impôt à la source alors plein de
gens m'ont dit ça marchera pas vous
allez voir ce que vous allez voir ce
sera difficile c'est dés j'en suis très
heureux la réforme la plus appréciée par
les Français du quinquennat du président
de la République précédent 88% de gens
considèrent que c'était une bonne
réforme on a changé la vie des agents
des finances publiques on a changé votre
façon de vivre l'impôt des choses plus
simples vous alliez plus vous avez pu la
trésorerie du coin vous avez désormais
des matérialisé votre enfant né vous
pouvez déclarer votre demi-part fiscal
vous avez un baisse de revenus pendant
le covid vous le déclarez immédiatement
bref nous avons modernisé le ministère
des Finances qui fonctionnait comme il y
a encore quasiment un siècle et
l'inversion de la pose sur le revenu par
par Monsieur par Monsieur caillou donc
ce que je souhaite c'est appliquer une
forme d'un poêle à source au ministère
de l'Intérieur évidemment dans des
conditions très différentes mais que ce
soit la plainte que ce soit le
renseignement que ce soit la possibilité
de travailler entre les forces pour les
forces elles-mêmes de parvenir au
commissariat moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que les effectifs que l'on crée ne
tiennent pas des postes dans les
commissariats mais soit dehors sur la
voie publique en lien directement avec
la population donc oui j'essaye
d'appliquer grâce aux moyens que
j'espère m'accordera le Parlement cette
transformation numérique qui est
extrêmement importante autre
transformation numérique qui relève de
la sécurité mais routières celles-ci mon
envie est de dématérialiser votre permis
de conduire votre carte grise afin
d'éviter les normes
usurpation d'identité qui existe et le
nombre de fraudes exponentielles sur les
véhicules qui sont revendus personne ne
comprend le nombre de points qu'il a sur
son permis de conduire puisque vous
recevez ça par lettre c'est toujours
décalé le policier qui vous contrôle ne
sait pas combien de points vous avez
alors que on pourrait tout à fait
imaginer que tout en gardant évidemment
quelque chose de physique pour ceux qui
veulent garder quelque chose de physique
vous ayez ce permis numérique soit par
QR code sur votre
voiture soit sur votre téléphone bref
vous l'avez comme vous le souhaitez on
puisse imaginer qu'on regarde si vous
avez votre assurance à jour si
effectivement vous êtes porteur d'une
carte pour personne handicapées ça
évitera sa tante de fraude combien de
points vous avez sur votre permis et
est-ce que c'est bien votre voiture que
vous êtes en train de conduire donc il y
a une modernisation à faire au ministère
de l'Intérieur qui dépasse bien sûr
celle de la simple sécurité sur les les
questions des sentinelles bon moi je
j'ai entendu j'ai vu le rapport de la
Cour des comptes et comme tout tous les
rapports de la Cour des comptes je les
regarde avec intérêt je n'ai pas été
d'accord avec leur conclusion puisque je
l'ai rendu public et ça c'est sûr
évidemment
les sentinelles
participent à la situation de notre pays
bon c'est un choix qui a été fait depuis
longtemps par plusieurs gouvernements si
nous décidons de te mettre de militaires
pour aider
la police et la gendarmerie alors il
faut recréer encore plus de poste de
policiers de Jordan parce que c'est un
des sujets évidemment pour nous que de
pouvoir lutter contre notamment
l'immigrations régulières aujourd'hui
par exemple nous faisons 10000 non
admissions d'étrangers irréguliers
parents à nos frontières italienne
espagnol quand c'était 3000 en 2019 donc
quand on a mis plus de force mobile et
plus de sentinelles on arrive à limiter
l'immigration irrégulière au prix de
beaucoup de gens spécialisés ce que ne
sont pas capables de faire les gendarmes
et les policiers
tout en haut des Alpes et de regarder
les passages de passeurs avec des moyens
technologiques que seuls les militaires
ont mais si demain il faut penser à
autre chose et président de la
République il y a pensé puisque dans sa
campagne électorale il a il a évoqué les
border force là border force un peu une
bordure force à l'australienne ce serait
d'imaginer que douane policier gendarme
armé puisse de manière spécialisée
pouvoir tenir nos frontières bon donc on
aura l'occasion de parler de cette
border force et sans doute qui répondra
à la fois le nom de la Cour des comptes
et sans doute au ministère des armées de
récupérer une partie de leur compatriote
sur leur la question de la sécurité
civile
alors vous avez posé beaucoup de
questions je vais essayer d'y répondre
madame la rapporteur nous avons
aujourd'hui une disponibilité
aérienne qui n'a pas de pareil en Europe
et surtout qui est la plus moderne
d'Europe est-ce que les suffisante la
réponse est non mais elle est cependant
constatons le la plus moderne et donc
nous l'espérons la plus efficace nous
avons aujourd'hui en termes d'avion
trois types d'avions 12 celle 415 7 Dash
8 et 3 benchcraft c'est trois avions
complètent une flotte d'hélicoptère qui
est intégralement renouvelé vous l'avez
vous-même dit dans la loopy aujourd'hui
un canadaire ça coûte à peu près 60
millions d'euros le problème n'est pas
d'acheter des canadaires le problème
c'est qu'il faut les produire et il y a
plus d'usine Canadair qui produit des
Canadairs c'est le problème donc on peut
parler des deux Canadair qu'on devait
attendre ils vont arriver en 2027 parce
que pour l'instant il faut d'abord qu'on
construise d'usines une fois qu'on aura
construit l'usine on pourra construire
les canadairs c'est la difficulté d'être
figure industrielle et pourquoi le
président a dit qu'il faut le faire au
niveau européen parce que c'est quand
même mieux vu la commande pour avoir des
industriels qui avaient 6 dans des
usines d'avions spécialisées tout le
monde n'achète pas à Canadair tous les
jours de dire voilà vous avez un nombre
de commandes d'assurer par une commande
publique et donc on peut produire ces
avions donc on achète pas des canadaires
par pas parce qu'au départ parce que
personne n'en produit si j'ose dire ou
l'équivalent du Canadair deuxièmement
sur les 35 hélicoptères moi je suis en
train de regarder si on peut pas
mutualiser avec la gendarmerie nationale
ces fameux hélicoptères parce que ce qui
est important c'est des on s'en sert pas
toujours des hélicoptères de sécurité
civile on s'en sert pour notamment
surveiller les feux il y a des moments
où quand même ce sont des feux il est
quand même un peu moins importantes que
d'autres et on pourrait utiliser ces
hélicoptères autrement alors je sais pas
si on y arrivera en tout cas je pense
qu'il y a des possibilités de
mutualisation pour pouvoir faire des
gains d'efficacité vous proposez
peut-être davantage encore de moyens et
rien par ses gains par ses gains gagnés
et donc lui cette flotte hélicoptère
sera entièrement
revue nous avons également
prévisions de 50 millions d'euros par
Canada juridique pour remplacer les 12
et nous souhaitons porter puisque sans
du président de la République de 12 à 16
le nombre de canadairs de notre propre
flotte sans compter la flotte européenne
appelée de ces vœux par le Président de
la République madame Cayeux était à
Bruxelles à ma demande la semaine
dernière pour en parler avec la
Commission et je reçois même le
Commissaire européen en charge la
sécurité civile dans les jours qui
viennent pour pour l'évoquer vous avez
évoqué le nombre de blessés je n'ai pas
exactement le nombre de blessés qu'il y
a eu dans tous ses feux mais il y a eu
deux pompiers décédés par suite de
malaise donc pas au feu mais revenant du
feu et je voudrais évidemment souligner
leur courage et avoir une pensée pour
leur pour leur famille et vous avez
évoqué la question
importante du numéro d'urgence et la loi
matras les décrets arrêtés sont en train
de sortir je vois l'occasion de le dire
samedi au Congrès des sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires
l'expérimentation ne dépend pas
seulement du de l'intérieur vous savez
madame la rapporteur que s'il ne
dépendait que du ministère d'intérieur
d'organiser un numéro d'urgence unique
ce serait plus simple il y a évidemment
d'autres ministères et notamment un
travail très important à faire sur la
régionalisation de ce numéro avec la
santé notamment mais on va trouver avec
Monsieur Brown inter Terra dansante moi
je souhaite que ce numéro
d'urgence non seulement correspondent la
loi dit à une région mais moi je sais
que les correspondants et une zone de
défense parce que ça a plus de cohérence
on voit bien que quel type de région
peuvent être concernés et ce sera assez
vite que nous allons mettre en place
cela c'est tout ce que s'il y avait un
raté en revanche on nous dirait mais
vous avez raté un appel du SAMU ou un
appel de pompier sur la régulation on me
dit qu'il y a eu 30 blessés dans les
feux de forêt vous voyez donc j'essaie
de répondre à votre à votre question sur
la question complémentaire sur les
questions complémentaire sur la les feux
de forêt et de manière générale des 10
bon notre difficulté c'est que
le financement des 10 madame la
sénatrice
c'est aussi un financement de
collectivité locale bon donc
si je peux me parler de ce Président
c'est impertinence venant d'un élu qui a
été élu départemental j'entends parfois
des présidents de vie je parle pas
spécifiquement du président de la
Gironde dire il nous faut plus de moyens
pour les pompiers alors la difficulté
c'est que quand on réclame la
décentralisation faut accepter aussi la
responsabilité qui va avec les
centralisation parce que si la
décentralisation consiste à demander à
l'état des moyens supplémentaires quand
on a décentralisé les compétences c'est
pas vraiment une décentralisation la
question qui se pose c'est désormais
quelle marge ont les 10 pour assurer les
moyens supplémentaires dont ils ont
besoin soit pour payer plus de pompiers
professionnels ça pour acheter plus de
matériel du fait notamment du
réchauffement climatique moi je constate
quand même qu'on a ce problème avec
cette taxe sur les assurances elle a été
créée pour financer S10 mais n'est pas
versé au 10 elle est versée au
département
qui ne verse pas l'intégralité de cette
recette au 10 donc la question qui se
pose c'est est-ce qu'on doit pas verser
directement la taxe OS 10 mais ça en
ferait une collectivité particulière
est-ce qu'on doit pas assurer une sorte
de miroir automatique si j'ose dire pour
que l'intégralité de cette texte iOS 10
est-ce que c'est la bonne taxe
d'ailleurs parce que la recette est
assez dynamique je pense que c'est pas
qu'une question état 10 c'est une
question aussi de comment on gère ces
flux de fiscalité mais on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler avec avec
la commission des lois jimenezchine
suite au rapport qu'on rendra
deuxièmement madame l'un des problèmes
qu'on a eu en Gironde mais c'est pas ça
le département et c'est très complexe et
très difficile et votre département
était particulièrement touché c'est
qu'il y a eu moins de 10% de pompiers
qui ont été mobilisés pendant les trois
premiers jours de l'incendie en Gironde
et donc sur 100% des pompiers de Gironde
seul 10% étaient mobilisé sur les feux
ce qui nous a demandé de demander des
pompiers d'ailleurs de venir alors sans
doute y a-t-il des raisons extrêmement
compréhensibles mais c'est pas toujours
une question de moyens c'est aussi une
question de disponibilité l'argent n'est
fait rien à faire dans ces cas-là c'est
juste que peut-être qu'on s'organise
tous collectivement on pourrait
s'organiser mieux pour mobiliser
davantage ça pour mobile parce que le
temps que les gens viennent du
Lot-et-Garonne et de Brest c'est plus
complexe pour éteindre le feu en
troisièmement je veux quand même redire
si vous ne permettez la question de la
base et une question que je peux
comprendre pour la Gironde qui a été
particulièrement touchée mais qui n'est
pas tout à fait satisfaisante en disant
on peut mettre des bases ailleurs le
grand avantage de la sécurité civile
française et c'est pour ça que l'Europe
va choisir sans doute je l'espère Nîmes
comme base européenne c'est que c'est la
disponibilité des appareils les
canadaires les dash ils ont besoin
d'être extrêmement
réparés pour pouvoir voler dans des
conditions de fortes pression ils sont
extrêmement sollicités et qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait là on les a on leur a
permis de voler le jour parce qu'ils
peuvent pas voler la nuit on les a
réparés la nuit et ça demande pas
simplement une base ça demande des
techniciens spécialisés ça demande du
matériel de pointe et c'est parce que
vous avez 10 cases à pareil que vous
arrivez à faire ces transformations si
vous avez sur la base de Nîmes c'est ce
que vous expliquerons les spécialistes
de sécurité civile si demain on a 30
avions on peut imaginer de base mais
c'est pas ce que nous avons aujourd'hui
après on peut prédisposer des avions
quelque part c'est ce qu'on fait encore
par exemple on met deux avions encore
donc là c'est à la sécurité civile c'est
pas moi de dire quels seront avec Météo
France les zones de risque pour
prépositionner des avions mais je suis
pas sûr que la base sur numéraire soit
forcément avec la flotte actuelle le bon
exemple voilà monsieur le Président
j'étais un peu long mais j'ai essayé
d'être complet merci nous avons encore
une petite série de questions je
demandais aux collègues de de réduire
alors oui j'ai pas répondu sur des
métropolisations
oui j'ai oublié de vous répondre madame
ben Vassa
alors pardon monsieur pardon madame la
sénatrice nous avons donc 1500 emplois
du ministère d'intérieur seront
démétropolisés c'est-à-dire retiré de
Paris et envoyer dans les villes de
province à l'échelle de 3 ans ça
concerne 20 villes à partir de 2023 et
2024 par exemple faroz considère à Lens
par exemple l'IGPN l'inspection générale
la police nationale ira au Havre donc on
a multiplié ce genre de délocalisation
par exemple le standard du ministère de
l'Intérieur ira à Limoges dès l'année
prochaine
c'est déjà ce que j'avais essayé de
faire à Bercy vous vous en souvenez
puisque j'ai des métropolisé 4000
emplois qui sont arrivés sur vos
territoires je pense que chacun les a vu
les a accueillis c'est à la fois un
meilleur cadre de vie pour beaucoup mon
pack Paris ne soit pas sympathique enfin
Paris a aussi ses défauts et parfois les
gens ont envie d'être en province un
meilleur cadre de vie ça permet ensuite
au grand débat du président de la
République dans des villes moyennes haut
de province de mettre de l'emploi public
et ça permet effectivement de faire
aussi des économies pour ministère de
l'Intérieur qui loue moins cher en
général ou qui achète moins cher des
sites au Havre qu'à Paris voilà donc on
le fait évidemment en toute seule
constatation sociale et syndicale il y a
aucune obligation pour les agents d'y
aller s'ils ne veulent pas y aller il
reste à Paris on le retrouve à notre à
notre job dans le ministère de
l'Intérieur et surtout ça permet de
jouer avec la pyramide des âges puisque
nous faisons un moment où nous allons
renouveler beaucoup de nos agents et
notamment de recruter localement un
certain nombre de personnels
bien alors Monsieur Bourgi on va essayer
d'être court il reste quelques questions
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre merci beaucoup pour les
éléments d'information que vous avez
bien voulu nous communiquer je vais à
mon tour saluer la sécurité civile à la
française dont nous pouvons être fiers
de la singularité de la spécificité de
l'efficacité mais dans votre
introduction vous avez indiqué
clairement qu'il fallait aujourd'hui
amorcer une nouvelle étape qui est celle
de la modernisation celle de
l'adaptation à un risque nouveau on a
beaucoup parlé de feu de forêt je
pourrais parler des inondations survenu
en Guadeloupe et je pourrais évoquer
malheureusement l'épisode méditerranéen
qui a annoncé pour ce week-end dans mon
département le département de l'Hérault
et les départements mitoyens à chaque
fois nous avons pu compter sur les
hommes et les femmes qu'on appelle
familièrement les soldats du feu nous
avons pu compter sur les comités
communaux de feu de forêt pour
s'impliquer cet été encore dans notre
département dans les départements
voisins et partout sur le territoire
français lors du PLF des débats qui ont
eu lieu nous avions été quelques-uns à
interroger votre collègue le ministre
Gabriel Attal sur un certain nombre de
mesures qui pourraient être mis en œuvre
assez rapidement parce que je ne vous le
cache pas la les budgets des 10 sont
très tendus pour cette année
nous avons évoqué naturellement et vous
l'avez fait à votre tour la question de
l'investissement dans le matériel temps
aérien que terrestre il se trouve que je
viens d'un département où depuis 20 ans
le département et le S10 à sa propre
flotte aérienne qui est basée sur
l'aéroport de Béziers Cap d'Agde donc
vous voyez parfois la décentralisation a
du bon et en l'occurrence en
l'occurrence là nous nous le prouvons
depuis 20 ans ceci étant dit je vous
propose d'aller un peu plus loin dans la
réflexion lors des débats sur le PLF
nous avons évoqué une façon d'aider de
manière très ponctuelle les 10 très
concrètement en les exonérant du
paiement du malus écologique pour les
véhicules qui servent pour les secours
nous avons évoqué la possibilité de les
exonérer aussi du paiement de la type
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'un véhicule
sort du centre de secours et d'incendie
c'est naturellement des frais des frais
de fonctionnement en carburant et donc
la type vient accentuer ce coûte
je voudrais aller plus loin dans la
réflexion peut-être que vous ne
répondrez aujourd'hui parce que ce sera
les débats que nous aurons dans
l'hémicycle à l'occasion de l'examen de
locmi ou du PDF qui nous permettront de
le faire je voudrais aussi évoquer la
question du débroussaillement on parle
beaucoup le débroussaillement qui sont à
la charge des propriétaires privés à la
charge des communes des collectivités et
on parle peu très peu je trouve du
débroussaillement des axes ferroviaires
et des axes terrestres qui concernent
cette fois-ci directement les sociétés
d'autoroute et qui concernent le Réseau
Ferré de France à la SNCF je viens dans
le département je viens d'une région où
malheureusement beaucoup de ces
incendies qui surviennent sur les
autoroutes et qui surviennent sur les
voies ferrées en été
proviennent de ces lieux-là et viennent
finalement
accentuer les conséquences pour les
estivants pour les vacanciers pour les
voyageurs pour les touristes
internationaux qui vont vers l'Espagne
ou qui remontent vers l'Europe du Nord
comment nous pouvons faire pour que le
débroussaillement soit appliqué de
manière plus coercitive par ces sociétés
d'autoroutes et par la SNCF et Réseau
Ferré de France je conclurai en évoquant
le courrier que je vous ai fait parvenir
ce matin vous le savez nous sommes 84
sénateurs à vous faire une proposition
toute simple afin de témoigner notre
considération et notre reconnaissance
pour les sapeurs-pompiers qui ont été
mobilisés cet été en vous proposant la
création d'une promotion exceptionnelle
de la médaille de la sécurité intérieure
avec agrafe de forêt 2022 cela ne coûte
pas cher et c'est une façon partout en
France de leur dire concrètement à
l'occasion d'une cérémonie très
symbolique le témoignage de la nation de
la reconnaissance de la nation que vous
avez exprimée tout à l'heure et que je
crois dans cette Haute Assemblée tout le
monde partage comme à l'Assemblée
nationale je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre merci madame de La Gontrie et
puis madame Gatel merci président
tout d'abord dans ce dans ce dans ce
projet de loi tout à l'heure j'ai réagi
vivement vous ne m'en voudrez pas mais
j'ai regardé vous aviez trois ans donc
je comprends que vous ne vous rappeliez
pas mais il y a déjà une loi de
programmation en tout cas dont je me
rappelais puisque je travaillais à
l'époque initiale intérieur c'est la loi
du 7 août 85 donc ça a déjà existé mais
que vous fassiez référence au grand
ministre Pierre Joxe me comble de
satisfaction voilà ma réaction tout à
l'heure je danse dans ce texte il y a un
chapitre sur la lutte contre les
violences intrafamilales mais qui dans
la dans la dans la faiblesse je dois
dire ma petit peu interpellé et donc
même si ce n'est pas de votre compétence
je pense mais plutôt de celle du garde
je pense que nous pourrions utilement
avancer vers la question de la
juridiction spécialisée sujet qui a déjà
été évoqué par la première ministre le
deuxième point c'est sur lequel je
voulais vous interroger nous sommes en
commission nous ne sommes pas dans nous
ne sommes pas télévision donc est-ce que
est-ce que vous pourriez nous dire
encore une fois il y a aucun esprit de
polémique de ma part comment vous
appréhendez et comment vous envisagez de
faire face à aux situations nées de ce
qu'on appelle communément les refus
d'obtempérer
nous savons l'actualité le monde qu'il y
a eu dans cette situation
9 morts depuis le début de l'année si je
dis en polémique vous n'avez jamais
entendu dire et je ne dirai jamais avec
la police tue donc on n'est pas du tout
dans un débat binaire
même s'il y a moins de policiers tués
désormais autrefois il n'empêche que un
Pélissier mort c'est un policier mort de
trop et que un policier qui tue est un
policier traumatisé je veux dire que on
n'oublie parfois aussi ce point pour
autant comment appréhendez-vous cette
situation est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut j'ai cru comprendre que les
syndicats n'y étaient pas forcément
hostiles retravailler sur la question
des techniques d'interpellation
est-ce que vous pensez que la loi de
2017 c'était avant l'élection de
d'Emmanuel Macron donc je ne fais pas de
procès qui a introduit dans le l435-12
items qui permettent semble-t-il une
plus grande latitude dans l'usage de
l'arme puisque pour l'un c'est la
possibilité
d'immobiliser un véhicule et je dis bien
un véhicule et non pas son conducteur
les deux articles les deux items je
pense faisaient suite à Charlie
c'est-à-dire à comment est-ce que on se
trouvait en situation de de voilà
d'arrêter quelqu'un qui pouvait
peut-être être dangereux ensuite bref
donc est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a
une question de formation de formation y
compris dans le champ juridique de
formation d'un point de vue technique
pour que tout simplement les policiers
concernés soit davantage formés dans une
situation d'extrême rapidité a plutôt
tirer dans les feux de tirer dans les
pneus de la voiture que voilà et afin
que que nous puissions ne plus constater
ces morts certains pourquoi son policier
donc encore une fois de ma part il n'y a
aucune polémique dans mon propos
merci madame monsieur laurier oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais vous interroger sur
le continuum de sécurité c'est à dire la
coopération entre les forces de police
nationale force de l'ordre national et
les polices municipales par rapport au
texte qui avait été présenté en mars
dernier il y a quelques mesures qui ont
totalement disparu du texte notamment et
je citerai deux exemples la possibilité
pour les communes de pouvoir se porter
partie civile lorsqu’un de ses élus
étaient victimes d'un crime ou d'un
délit ou encore la modification du droit
funéraire en permettant que les
opérations notamment de surveillance et
de scellement du cercueil passe sous la
responsabilité du maire en présence
notamment de la gare de champêtre ou
éventuellement d'un agent de police
municipale transfert qui était
compenser à travers à travers la finance
alors ma question est très simple est-ce
que c'est ces deux mesures symboliques
sont définitivement abandonnés si oui
pourquoi ou seront-elles reprises dans
une autre dans un autre texte au projet
de loi merci
et Madame l'herbier
oui monsieur le ministre votre texte a
pour objectif de prendre un bras le
corps l'espace stratégique est devenu le
cyber et je tenais à vous saluer pour
cette initiative parce qu'elle est plus
que nécessaire et que la France avait
vraiment un réel retard le forum
international de cybersécurité de la
gendarmerie se réunit tous les ans à
Lille et un immense succès il nous
expose très souvent des besoins humains
très difficiles à combler vous avez
annoncé le recrutement de 400
fonctionnaires et contractuels de haut
niveau pour mettre en oeuvre les projets
numériques indispensables au ministère
initiative louable les moyens semblent
très importants cependant le nombre de
développeurs sont en effet très
recherchés par tous types d'institutions
et d'entreprises très recherchée ils
sont le nerf de la guerre numérique
ils ont un coût très élevé
il y aura une concurrence avec le
secteur privé pour recruter c'est
personnels comment le ministère
souhaite-il les convaincre de s'engager
à ses côtés
merci Madame
terminez pour les questions celui des
réponses
dire qu'elle a raison mais je pense que
c'est pas qu'une question de
rémunération même si c'est une question
de rémunération c'est une question de
sens dans le métier et je pense qu'il y
a plein de gens aujourd'hui plein de
jeunes notamment qui cherchent un sens à
leur métier et qu'il faut qu'on puisse
dire que l'État c'est le cas des
services de renseignement on croule sous
les candidatures parce que je pense que
chacun voit que défendre son pays et les
téléfilms n'ont pas simplement aider à
ça il s'agit aussi d'engagement citoyen
on préfère même lorsqu'on vit dans un
monde informatique être moins bien payé
mais travailler pour l'État dans des
conditions de valorisation de ce qu'on
fait je pense que c'est ce qu'on doit
trouver au ministère de l'Intérieur si
j'ose dire j'essaierai de faire au
ministère de l'Intérieur ce que encore
une fois il y a quelques années on a
fait dans l'armée métier et je crois que
les armées ont réussi à montrer qu'en
changeant d'images en attirant les gens
très différents
divers dans lequel vous pouvez faire un
passage d’ailleurs pas forcément toute
leur carrière le problème de la police
nationale gendarmerie nationale sans
doute c'est que recrute beaucoup de gens
dans des conditions sans doute difficile
et d'urgence parce qu'on prévoit pas
toujours ces promotions en décalant des
concours l'image du policier de gendarme
peut être largement amélioré il va
devenir un policier un gendarme
augmenter par les moyens technologiques
qu'on va lui qu'on va lui donner et sans
doute la diversification des profils
n'est pas d'autres façons de faire les
gendarmes un peu plus que les policiers
mais j'ai demandé à l'École
polytechnique par exemple de réserver
quatre places de commissaire de police
pour que nous ayons enfin si j'ose dire
des ingénieurs dans la police nationale
ils portent des projets numériques
extrêmement importants c'est des
commissaires de police qui s'en occupent
c'est quand même un métier d'ingénieur
parfois de porter des projets
informatiques des recrutements sur
titres qui sont pas assez fait et on
passe toujours par la voix du concours
classique alors que les gendarmes font
en partie là il y a quand même une
diversification de choses qu'on va faire
des échanges avec des entreprises qui
sont tout à fait tout à fait possible et
puis surtout une formation continue
efficace que nous faisons aujourd'hui ok
aussi je pense une question de sens et
publicité positive bien sûr peut-être
en revenant à beau monsieur pour
Monsieur Bougy moi j'entends votre
question moi j'ai jamais dit que la
décentralisation était pas efficace je
suis décentralisateur je dis juste qu'il
y a une part de responsabilité dans la
dans la décentralisation bien évidemment
ce qui n'empêche pas de bien travailler
ensemble bien sûr il y a des
départements qui ont fait un certain
nombre d'innovations qu'on ne faisait
pas l'état c'est quelqu'un de votre
département je le reconnais bien bien
volontiers et qu'il faut qu'on puisse
par ailleurs par ailleurs encouragé vous
avez mis le fois raison sur les feux qui
naissent des aires d'autoroute et là ça
s'est vu particulièrement cet été des
feux de broussailles qui venaient des
voix SNCF et dans un feu qui a eu lieu
cet été dans les Bouches-du-Rhône qui a
fait des centaines d'hectares de de de
dégâts on a vérifié qu'effectivement la
scène ça fait bien entretenu sa voix
mais la sécheresse c'était tellement
forte et par ailleurs le fait que ce
soit sec et l'idométrie tellement parce
que le grincement des des rails ont fait
naître quand même des étincelles qui ont
quand même propagé ce feu donc peut-être
que c'est pas simplement l'entretien
c'est peut-être revoir l'entretien alors
du réchauffement climatique alors ça
dépasse les compétences puisque c'est
Monsieur bichu qui en est le responsable
mais il est sûr qu'on doit sans doute
faire des exigences différentes
désormais alors de réchauffement
climatique dans l'entretien et notamment
vous l'avez très bien dit pour les
sociétés d'autoroute ou pour les
délaisser pas pour les dresser pour les
voies pour les voies SNCF alors vous
m'avez posé des questions sur les
incitations fiscales ou les aides malus
bonus que l'on peut faire
malheureusement je crois que ce soit du
domaine de Bercy et que Bercy a déjà dit
non et je crois même qu'il a dit non au
nom du droit européen mais mais voilà
j'ai bien noté la question et je propose
que on la relaye oui et 1000 fois oui
pour une promotion spécifique de
décoration avec une agrafe feu de forêt
j'aurais dû d'ailleurs l'annoncer dans
un déplacement à Bordeaux qui a dû être
annulé pour pour cause de de d'actualité
un peu brûlantes au mystère de
l'intérieur je le renoncer à ce là mais
je suis bien bien volonté de le faire en
lien avec vous et avec les sénateurs et
vos collègues le président de la
République va recevoir les acteurs de la
sécurité civile à l'Elysée notamment
tous ceux qui ont contribué pas que les
pompiers mais aussi les pompiers assez
feux de forêt cet été et je lui ai
proposé qu'il puisse aussi remettre
quelques décorations c'est rare qu'un
président de la République le fasse de
ce niveau de de médaille mais en tout
cas oui je suis tout à fait d'accord et
on fera cette promotion avec agrafe feu
de forêt
madame la sénatrice madame de La Gontrie
vous avez raison sur les violences
intrafamiliales il y a quand même une
citation très importante c'est la
création de 2000 postes supplémentaires
de d'enquêteurs ça fait partie un peu
les OPJ c'est c'est un peu le mal aussi
pour les enquêtes intrafamiliales
puisque s'il y a des interpellations
s'il y a des gens qui se regardent à vue
il y a tellement de procédures vous le
savez désormais qu'on doit mettre un
nombre d'enquêteurs très important pour
pouvoir répondre dans la rapidité de de
la protection des des femmes et des
enfants et nous ne le faisons pas
toujours par manque d'epj donc je
voudrais comme souligner que dans les
8500 créations de postes il y a non
seulement cela mais il y a aussi les
accompagnements sociaux de psychologue
ou d'assistante sociale ou d'assistants
sociaux qu'on mettra à disposition des
commissariats et des brigades de
gendarmerie mais vous avez parfaitement
raison moi je suis convaincu que la
justice spécialisée comme c'est le cas
en Espagne va nous aider à être plus
efficace voilà donc la première ministre
la annoncé Isabelle Rome le porte la
porte également cette justice
spécialisée elle qui a été magistrate
notamment dans ce domaine en tout cas
politiquement si je peux me permettre de
donner mon opinion personnel je suis
assez persuadé que ce que font nos amis
espagnols est une est une chose plus
efficace je voudrais quand même
souligner avec vous mais mais vous le
savez sur les 30 il y a 30 féminines 30%
des féminicides que nous avons connu
l'année dernière qui était en lien avec
la police ou la justice laquelle il y
avait un signalement une plainte une
main courante ou un signalement la
justice c'est-à-dire qu'il y a quand
même 70%
pesticides et qui malheureusement
n'aurait peut-être pas pu éviter par la
police à gendarmerie en améliorant notre
process par la justice par des faits des
petits faits comme dirait Stendhal qui
ne relève pas des pouvoirs publics
police justice la question des médecins
par exemple est quand même question
importante la façon dont on signale cela
et donc c'est pas parce qu'on tant mieux
si on se spécialise la justice tant
mieux se met davantage de moyens dans la
police et la gendarmerie tant mieux que
nous soyons tous mieux formés
aujourd'hui 150000 policiers gendarmes
formés sur les 250 000 et l'intégralité
des écoles de police gendarmerie
désormais formés donc on peut toujours
s'améliorer mais je veux quand même
souligner que il y a des faits qui
auraient pu nous être signalés un peu
comme dans le cadre de la pédophilie par
les médecins qui vous le savez sont
obligés de le dire quand il s'agit d'un
enfant de moins de 15 ans qui pourrait
être plus efficace par exemple alors je
sais qu'elle se crée médical je sais que
c'est très complexe mais mais je crois
que vous le savez ce n'est pas qu'un
sujet de police et de justice même si
c'est aussi un sujet de police et de
justice
sur les reflets de tempérer non non mais
j'ai bien compris votre question non
polémique et croyez mieux que le mise à
l'intérieur lui-même se pose se pose des
questions parce que malheureusement hier
j'étais auditionné à l'Assemblée
nationale j'ai préparé les fiches de la
nuit il y avait si refus d’obtempérer
hier dans la nuit de lundi à mardi et
j'ai pu les égrainer et j'ai vu que
d'ailleurs à Nantes une dame qui n'est
rien à voir avec le tempérée et je crois
entre la vie et la mort parce que elle a
subi le refus de tempérer c'était pas à
cause du policier c'était pas à cause de
cette dame mais elle s'est faite je
crois percuter et donc évidemment c'est
des drames à chaque fois quelque soit
ses drames et je veux bien le souligner
merci d'avoir aussi souligné que même
quand le policier tire et qu'il est dans
son endroit de tirer c'est toujours un
traumatisme alors les reflets de
tempérer ils ont augmenté de 13% depuis
2016 puisque vous me posez la question
du constat on en a 27609 exactement 2021
police et gendarmerie compris contre
24409 en 2016 aujourd'hui on a toutes
les 30 minutes en zone police en zone
gendarmerie il y a quand même eu 41
policiers gendarmes BC gravement depuis
le 1er janvier on en parle peu on parle
des morts bien sûr on parle des tirs
mais il y a aussi tous ceux qui ne
tirent pas et qui se font quand même
écrasés par un véhicule 41 blessé grave
dans les forces de l'ordre c'est
vraiment très très important alors
est-ce que la loi 2017 finalement a à
améliorer si j'ose dire les choses ou
est-ce qu'elle les a gravées moi j'ai
tendance à penser que c'est pas tout à
fait le sujet parce que si je regarde
les chiffres police et gendarmerie
compris ils sont 37 tirs en 2016
il y a eu 200 de tirs en 2017 où la loi
n'était pas encore applicable puisqu'il
n'y avait pas encore les décrets il est
pas con d'instruction de la police
nationale gendarmerie il y a eu 170 tirs
en 2018 il 147 tirs en 2019 et 153 en
2020 mais enfin c'était des années covid
donc il y avait moins de gens sur la
route donc parfois il y en a quand même
beaucoup pour des gens qui ne méritaient
pas d'être sur la route à ce moment-là
et il y en a eu dans toute l'année 2021
157 c'est à dire qu'on a eu moins en
2021 qu'en 2018 l'écran 2017 donc je
vous dis pas qu'il faut pas améliorer
encore la formation qu'on peut regarder
encore combien de choses peuvent
fonctionner parce que vous avez tout à
fait raison on devrait apprendre à tout
le monde de tirer dans les endroits non
les taux dans des particuliers dans des
moments particuliers mais vous vous
accorderez avec moi que lorsqu'on est
policier gendarme qu'on est sur la route
qui fait nuit que la voiture roule très
très vite bon
je parle le premier pas comme une
provocation mais c'est plus facile à
dire assis ici que sur la route donc
cependant ce sont des professionnels de
la sécurité qui doivent agir dans un
cadre déontologique et moi j'ai demandé
au directeur général de la gendarmerie
nationale et de la police nationale de
réfléchir ensemble à ce qu'on pouvait
améliorer il y a aussi ceux qui me
disent pourquoi vous faites pas comme
les Britanniques puisque il y a ceux qui
comme vous nous disent bon peut-être que
pour voir la formation à déontologie ce
qui est évidemment important quand on
est le chef de cette administration il y
a aussi tous ceux qui me disent vous
n'êtes pas encore assez dur il faut
faire du tamponnage en direct bon moi je
veux redire que la doctrine de la police
nationale gendarmerie est assez clair
elle consiste évidemment lorsqu'elle
refusent d'obtempérer à pouvoir
poursuivre la personne qui commet se
refuse de tempérer et d'arrêter cette
poursuite lorsque les policiers les
gendarmes considèrent que pour eux-mêmes
ou pour un tiers c'est poursuite a plus
de conséquences négatives qu'elle n'a
davantage que d'arrêter la personne
puisque de toute façon de manière
générale la police gagne toujours à la
fin ça fait pas la une des médias mais
trois jours après grâce aux caméras de
vidéoprotection grâce aux caméras
piétons grâce à des signalements on
arrive à retrouver la quasi intégralité
des personnes qui commettent ces méfaits
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas sur le
coup ça peut paraître frustrant pour
pour tout le monde donc c'est sûr qu'il
y a une part de difficultés dans
l'action de savoir à partir de quand
c'est de poursuite devient dangereuse
pour un tiers comme pour cette dame de
Nantes et à partir du moment où on
laisse faire n'importe quoi sur le sur
la voie République moi je veux dire une
vérité de la Pallice qu'on dit assez peu
quand un policier un gendarme vous
demande de vous arrêter il faut vous
arrêter pardon de cette de cette
topologie mais mais elle est bonne à
rappeler on constate malheureusement par
défaut de permis de conduire
c'est beaucoup d'enquête démontre
désormais que le retrait de permis de
conduire pardon non non ça justifie
peut-être le nombre de refus
d'obtempérer qui augmentent par
transport de produits malheureusement
stupéfiants on l'a vu à 11 ans dans le
Nord il transportait la dent ils étaient
un trafiquant de drogue et par l'arme
qui se transforme par destination qui
est la voiture voilà il y a il y a cette
difficulté d'augmentation des refus moi
je constate que 13% d'augmentation
depuis 2016 en plus des refuses
intempéries mais grosso modo 10% de
moins de tir par rapport 2017 et 2016
peut-être que médiatiquement on les met
plus en avant désormais c'est ça peut
être une des raisons et sans doute qu'il
faut continuer à faire ce travail de
formation et de et de déontologie mais
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il y a une
inflation
très très importante de s'étire même si
à chaque fois c'est un drame un drame
pour tout le monde je veux quand même
souligner madame la sénatrice le fait
que aujourd'hui les policiers et les
gend dans des conditions
d'insécurité assez forte connaissent la
première mortalité du fait des refus de
tempérés
c'est pas par mal qui meurt le plus de
policiers gendarmes c'est écrasé par un
véhicule voilà et donc mon objet de
constater aussi mais enfin si le Sénat
venait à faire un centre de travaux sur
ce sujet je l'accompagnerai bien
évidemment volontiers pour monsieur le
sénateur alors moi je suis un peu embêté
parce que
si on fait des textes trop longs on dit
c'est trop long et puis maintenant qu'on
essaie plus court on dit mais il manque
des articles mais vous avez raison je
suis favorable aux dispositions que vous
évoquez puisque je les avais proposé en
premier texte si vous le souhaitez qu'on
les adopte en abonnement
je donnerai qu'un ami favorable à ces
conditions ce qu'on a essayé de faire
c'est devant la majorité plus complexe
de la sommet national je vous dis tout
moi j'ai obéi à la consigne de la
première ministre dire faisons des
textes courts pour éviter des
discussions interminables donc je fais
de la politique c'est à dire j'essaie de
m'adapter aux événements je suis à la
disposition des événements comme dirait
Talleyrand voilà non mais en vrai
on a sorti un certain nombre de
disposition qui nous paraissait pas
profondément essentiel vous savez ce que
vous évoquez pour le pouvoir du maire
c'est ce que j'ai vécu comme maire donc
je dis toujours je la mise à l'intérieur
je changerai ça je serais très heureux
que la chambre des territoires me fasse
modifier ce genre de choses vous avez
aussi évoqué la loi sécurité globale et
l'amélioration pour les polices
municipales je veux dire grâce au
sénateur de Bresse et à vous tous que
désormais les politiciens ont accès au
SIV ou SNPC à la fourrière et au snussy
au snussy pardon et nous allons bientôt
permettre le docu verif le FPR c'est un
grand débat monsieur le ministre et le
10ème fichier au police municipale il y
a pas disposition police municipale ça
peut interroger mais parce que le
Conseil constitutionnel a été clair soit
malheureusement bon j'ose dire soit les
polices municipales ont des pouvoirs
judiciaires et dans ces cas là faut les
mettre à disposition des procureurs de
la République je crois qu'il y a pas
beaucoup de maires de France qui
aimeraient que leur prise municipale
soit désormais à l'expédition du
procureur de la République soit il faut
changer la Constitution pour permettre
une séparation des pouvoirs différents
ce serait un peu disproportionné sans
doute pour le pouvoir des polices
municipales
trouvera naturellement en séance pour le
texte mais en commission avant pour les
rapports de messieurs dobresse et Hervé
merci à tous bonne soirée merci encore